So, schon wieder Stream Leute, jetzt gehts ja schla- Moment, Vorschau, warum sparkt das
immer so rum, ah jetzt, exellent, geht ja Schlag auf Schlag hier, so viele Streams
Alter. Ja und zwar, ich hab gesehen, es gibt seit Mai oder seit irgendwie seit ein paar
Monaten, gibt es eine neue Proxmox Version, ich bin ja bisher nicht so großartig damit
warm geworden, was aber nicht heißt, was das nicht für andere eine gute Sache ist,
also gute Lösung ist für das was wir machen wollen und der hauptsächliche Grund warum
ich jetzt ausprobiere, ich hab mir mal hier die neuen Idee, nee, Ideas, nicht Idee, aber
fast so aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen, was mich, was ich ganz interess- Moment, warum ist das
auf Deutsch? Können wir das auf Englisch stellen? Exellent, achso, stimmt, die kommen ja aus
Österreich die Typen, und zwar, ich hab gelesen, dass man jetzt DNS, also erstens hab ich gelesen,
dass die jetzt Let's Encrypt machen können, oh nee, Splatoon Musik hör mal auf, Splatoon
ist so ein Spiel, das verwirrt mich hochgradig, also nicht das Spiel an sich, sondern das
Internet und ihr könnt euch wahrscheinlich denken, was ich meine, das Internet ist bei
sowas immer auf Zack, ein bisschen laut hier, so und zwar, also warum ich es jetzt noch mal
ausprobiere, hauptsächlich ist das hier, weil ich gelesen hab, die machen jetzt Let's Encrypt
Zertifikate und die können auch DNS-Challenges, das ist ja das was ich hauptsächlich verwende,
ah, jetzt ist der Stream am Start, den haben wir hier, den Toaster ist noch dabei, das
Skillkiller, Captain Peng, der ist auch öfters am Start, sind alle öfters am Start, ich
kenne ja mittlerweile die üblichen Verdächtigen, Easykiller ist auch am Start, Pengi, das sind
wieder hier alle am Start, die man so kennt, aber in letzter Zeit, ich hab mal geguckt,
kommen immer mehr Leute random vorbei, also vermute ich zumindest mal, weil wenn ich so
die Followerzahlen angucke, die gehen immer richtig schön rauf pro Stream, jetzt mein,
das ist jetzt nicht so wie auf YouTube, wo sich das irgendwie 30-40.000 Leute angucken,
aber ich mein, es ist auch kein YouTube Content, ja, so und ich mein, was geht mit der Musik
ab, das ist ja aber nicht, what the fuck, das ist schon besser, so, ich mein, das ist natürlich
jetzt keine Geschichte hier von wegen YouTube, irgendwie mit, wo man unter 500 Abos am Tag
nicht zufrieden ist oder so, ähm, gut, bei mir ist ja eh egal, aber, weil das stimmt
schon gar nicht, weil es ist mittlerweile mehr, es kommen jeden Stream neue Sachen, neue Leute
dazu, das finde ich extrem nice und das ohne, dass ich irgendwo Werbung mache, so muss das
sein, ich mache hier meine ganzen Kram zu, speichern wir mal, brauchen wir vielleicht
noch, so, ähm, genau, wie gesagt, ich hab gelesen, die machen jetzt letztens eine Crypt-Zertifikate,
und die machen DNS-Challenge, vielleicht probieren wir das mal aus, mal gucken, ähm,
da müsste ich nämlich irgendwo meine Cloudflare Zugangsdaten raussuchen und da hab ich Schiss,
dass ich die im Zweifels verlieke, deswegen belasse ich es vielleicht mal eher bei dem,
dass sie es jetzt können, war das Beep im Stream, also bei mir hat nichts gepiepst,
hat es bei euch gepiepst, das ist tatsächlich wahr, die Streams, wo ich einfach nur Videos
gucke und auf irgendwas reakte, werden am meisten geguckt, was eigentlich so der ultra
low effort Content ist, aber der geht, übrigens Leute, ist euch aufgefallen, ich hab die Kamera
upgraded, das sieht jetzt besser aus, ja, weiß nicht, ob man das erkennt, aber es ist
jetzt 1080p, es ist jetzt 1080p und ich zeig euch gleich noch was tolles, was man damit
jetzt machen kann, man kann nämlich die Kamera anmachen, zeige euch das gleich mal, zeige
euch das gleich mal, chat, wie, wie, also, man kann jetzt mal,
keine Ahnung, mal jetzt besser, wie, hat man das jetzt gar nicht gesehen, was ich gemacht
habe gerade, oh nee, Moment, jetzt kann ich jetzt das Licht anmachen, weiß nicht, ob das
besser aussieht, sieht das besser aus als ohne Licht, ich finde das sieht total so Krankenhaus
mäßig aus, sieht man jetzt besser was, man sieht die Kiste, die daneben steht, ja, vielleicht,
ich weiß nicht, vielleicht, wir testen noch mal, wie high quality die Kamera ist, läuft
noch, läuft, gut, dann funktioniert's, Handlig, OMFG, Handlig,
gut, also wenn das besser aussieht mit Beleuchtung, mal gucken wie langs das, mal gucken wie langs
das iPhone durchhält, ob man da stundenlang die Kamera bzw. nee nicht die Kamera, ob man
da stundenlang die Beleuchtung anlassen kann, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, übrigens, was
man hier wieder schön erkennt ist, oder für die Leute, die nicht dabei, findet ihr es
nicht merkwürdig, dass da ein PCI Express Stecker mitten auf dem Mainboard ist, ich
meine, dass da unten ein PCI Express Stecker ist, kennt man ja, aber warum ist da ein PCI
Express Stecker, das ist wirklich Big Brain Adapter, das ist M2 auf PCI Express, das wusste
ich bis, als ich dafür gekauft hab, gar nicht, dass es das überhaupt gibt, ja, so und zwar,
das ist die gleiche Kiste, ich wollte weder Synology noch Proxmox will ich wirklich dauerhaft
verwenden, ich hab hier daneben meine Kiste stehen, wo alles drauf ist, wie ich's hab,
wobei ich wirklich ernsthaft am überlegen bin, ob ich mir da nicht Synology drauf haue,
ich wollte zwar eigentlich keine VMs laufen lassen, weil es das immer von der Verwaltung
ein bisschen komplizierter macht, aber ich bin ernsthaft am überlegen, ob ich da nicht
noch jetzt ne KVM Synology Kiste drauf mach, nee das ist jetzt einfach nur zum ausprobieren
und außerdem interessiert es mich, was die so Neues machen, verwenden will ich das eher
nicht, wie gesagt für so ein ESX Style Unterbau hab ich da einen, ja weiß nicht ob sich das
lohnt, also für mich ist es am einfachsten, für mich ist es am einfachsten, wenn dann
stinknormaler Ubuntu Server drauf ist, ich klatsch ein paar Dinger drauf, die ich brauchen
gut ist, wofür steht denn das VE Founders Edition, ich hab keine Ahnung für was das
steht, Version, nee ich hab keine Ahnung für Virtual Environment, keine Ahnung für was
steht, Proxmox Wikipedia, guck mal mal, Proxmox Virtual Environment, kurz PVE, kannst du
jetzt einen Kripp dann unter Proxmox testen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich das kann,
weil dann müsste ich mein Cloudflare API Key leaken, also dann leake ich vielleicht mein
Cloudflare API Key und das sackt, nee DDoSn ist mein kleinste Problem was ich hab, wenn
ich mein Cloudflare API Key leake, weil er darf alles machen, ich könnte mir einen Cloudflare
Account erstellen für, ich könnte mal einen Cloudflare, oder wenn da Sebaro da ist, wenn
da Sebaro da ist, dann können wir das über die Domain vom Sebaro machen, wenn man da
irgendeinen DNS Only API Key erstellen kann, oder wir machen es über pepofet, nee pepof.at,
beste Domain, war das pepof.at, nee ah ich hab vergessen wie die Domain war, der Sebaros
mit dem Physik Grill beschäftigt hat, das wäre ja gut für ihn, genau, jetzt mal gucken
was die was die Neues haben, also es gibt einen aktuellen Kern, es gibt neues ZEV Gedöns,
wobei ZEV brauch ich ja nicht, so erstmal hier Chat aufmachen, dass ich wieder ein paar
Sachen hochscrollen kann, achso und was wir auch ausprobieren nachher, alter warum merkt
er sich nie, dass ich Dark Mode haben will, ja was wir auch ausprobieren ist eine Runde
PCI Pass Thru, und zwar ich hab hier noch sowas, ich halte es mal kurz in die Kamera,
es ist eine 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte von Ebay, mal gucken ob die dann erkennt und ob das
funktioniert, schauen wir mal, doch es gibt beim Linux können wir öfters mal LTS Version,
allerdings verwende ich schon ewig keine LTS Version, weil ich Manjaro verwende und
bin eigentlich ganz froh damit, bin so wie es ist, so also, Herr Kelmer schreibt überlege
mir, mal gucken ob es meinen Chatlogger mitgekriegt hat, nee das da, schreibt hier überlege mir
meine Windows Gaming Vm mit Pass Thru, nee würde ich nicht machen, das macht mehr Probleme,
überlege mir meine Windows, also ich lese es mal vor, überlege mir meine, und so, überlege
mir meine Windows Gaming Vm mit Pass Thru GPU statt KVM nun zu Proxmox zu verschieben
schreibt er, und mein Hauptdesktop Linus auch in eine Vm zu verschieben, da es mir mittlerweile
so viele Probleme macht die ein Reboot des Hostsystems erfordern, da würde ich nicht
machen, würde ich nicht machen, du hast, das klingt auf den ersten Blick verlockend, aber
ich bin mir sicher wenn du es verwendest kriegst du ordentliche Probleme, das erste was mir
so spontan einfällt ist, dass immer mehr Games checken ob man in der Vm läuft, beispielsweise
dieses eine Ding was ja gerade, was auch der Friseur spielt hier, dieses komische Aja Ja
Game, das ist zwar eine Singleplayer Game, aber die haben den Anti-Cheat, die gucken
ob man in der Vm läuft, und wenn man in der Vm läuft, dann ist nicht Aja Ja, dann geht
nicht, also ich weiß nicht, ich, gerade was Gaming und Windows angeht, ist so ein Ding,
wo ich den größten Vorteil nutzen will, und zwar, dass man die Sache einfach anschalten
kann und es geht meistens, so und das ist auch der Grund warum ich nicht großartig rum
experimentiere, auch wenn wir das mal in ein paar nächsten Streams ausprobieren, also
das ist übrigens auch eine Sache, die müssen wir unbedingt machen, wenn ich es dann wirklich
hinkriege mal, ich mag keine Splatoon Musik, so, wenn ich es dann doch mal hinbekommen
sollte mir einen neuen Rechner zu kaufen, das liegt aber eher an der Verfügbarkeit
von Grafikkarten und neuen CPUs, wenn ich es dann hinkriege neuen Rechner, dann testen
wir auf dem alten Gaming Rechner, mal Linux mit Proton und Wine und Gaming Zeug, so,
ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich dann übelst flamen werde wahrscheinlich, und dann alle
sagen Max, warum regst du dich so auf, dann musst du halt mal 3 Stunden basteln, dass
du ein Spiel zum Laufen kriegst, ist doch nicht schlimm, dafür brauchst du kein Windows,
aber irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ich finde es geil, dass ich teilweise als Linux
Fanboys mich dann hier im Stream manchmal mit Linux Fanboys schlagen muss, wenn ich
irgendwas negatives sage, was ich nicht gut finde, oh nein, nein, nein, das liegt da nicht
dran, das kann überhaupt nicht sein, zumindest eine Sache finde ich gut, also was hier anders
ist, als auf YouTube, wenn ich auf YouTube irgendwelche Videos gemacht habe, wo es um
Technik Sachen geht, zum Beispiel, ich hatte ja mal was gemacht über Meltdown, da habe
ich ja sogar, also ich meine, das war, man darf, man darf das mal, Moment, sag mal, hat
die PC Welt mein Thumbnail, das sieht ja fast genauso aus wie mein Thumbnail, alter, zumindest
ich habe auf YouTube mal ein Video gemacht, über Shellshock und Heartbleed und Meltdown
und solche Geschichten, und ich habe das am gleichen Tag gemacht, ist die Musik gar
nicht zu laut, zu leise, passt so, ich habe das am gleichen Tag gemacht, und ich muss
euch sagen, ich kann mich noch drehen, das ist ungefähr zweieinhalb Jahre her, und ich
habe das am gleichen Tag gemacht, und ich habe mir sogar extra das Original Paper durchgelesen,
was die, war das nicht an irgendeiner Schweizer Uni, war das nicht an irgendeiner, an irgendeiner,
ich zeig das Paper doch hier drin, oh ja, meine Arraymal-Künste, legend, ja, zeigt
das, zumindest ich hab mir sogar das Original, die Originalveröffentlichung davon angeguckt,
ja, war das die ETH Zürich, Einstein wäre Scholz, ja, ich hab keine Ahnung, es war aber
glaube ich nicht die ETH Zürich, Meltdown, Bug, Discovery, welche, welche, waren das
noch mal, Hamburg, hier, Graz, Graz, wie spricht man daraus, Graz, das heißt bestimmt Graz,
weil wir sehen da nicht in MMOs, genau, da haben sie das entdeckt, GZ, GG, GZ, GL, und
ich hab am gleichen Tag dieses Video gemacht über Meltdown, das heißt ich hab mir das
Paper so weit durchgelesen und das ist wirklich nicht ohne, also zum größten Teil ist das
okay, aber die Details waren nicht ohne, vor allem das hier, wo ich es hier gerade im Video
hab, wo es darum ging, was die hier für Assembler-Dinger machen, dass man das ausnutzen kann, also
nur mal so zur Erklärung, nur mal ganz, ganz kurz rückwirkend, der Trick bei Meltdown,
Alter, was hat der denn mit seiner Splatoon-Musik, das geht mir voll auf den Keks, ich mag keine
Splatoon-Musik, das Mario Kart, also bei Meltdown ging es nicht darum, dass man auf Sachen zugreifen
kann, auf die man nicht zugreifen können sollte, so ohne weiteres, nein, bei Meltdown
hat man die Zugriffszeiten gemessen und konnte dadurch erkennen, was schon mal gecashed war
und was nicht, so, ganz, ganz grob und dadurch konnte man quasi anhand des Indexes, welcher
gecashed war, erkennen, welcher Wert ausgelesen wurde aus dem Bereich, den man eigentlich
ausgelesen können sollte, so, also Meltdown war wirklich ein bisschen durch die Brust
ins Auge, so, und ich hab am gleichen Tag ein Video gemacht und ich muss sagen, also
ich finde, dass das zumindest im deutschsprachigen Raum das beste Video zum Thema für Leute
war, die das nicht täglich machen, Spectre und Meltdown waren sich recht ähnlich, aber
das war Meltdown, was ich da in dem Video erklärt hab, so, zumindest, warum ich das
jetzt alles erzähle ist, ich muss jetzt mal öfters mit irgendwelchen Linux-Fanboys diskutieren
auf dem Stream, ich mein, ich bin ja selber einer, aber deswegen find ich das besonders
lustig, aber eine Sache ist hier, ist hier nicht, ist hier im Stream nicht so, jedes
mal, wenn ich auf YouTube so ein Video mache, warum ich jetzt so lang aushole ist, das Video
war echt nicht ohne und das war schon ein bisschen Research dabei und das war auch nicht
einfach und alles, aber du hast hier, wenn du die Kommentare durchrollst, wieder so, Max,
Max, sehr viel gefährliches Halbwissen verbreitet, hättest du mal genauer schauen sollen und
solche, solche Wichtig-Tour, die haben wir hier im Stream nicht, hier im Stream haben
wir manchmal Leute, die gehen wir zwar auch auf dem Kickstarter, aber nicht so dieses typische
YouTube-Dummgelaber, was es immer gegeben hat.
Ja, so sieht's aus, ja, das ist ja okay, da hat er ja auch recht, da war ich ein bisschen
schnell, so, aber, ist das Twilight Princess, ja, naja, und das haben wir, das haben wir
hier im Stream glücklicherweise nicht, das ist auch das, was mir an YouTube am meisten
auf den Keks geht, das ist so eine Sache, die mich an YouTube am meisten motiviert und
am meisten auf den Keks geht und zwar, einmal lese ich gerne Comments von Leuten und da
gibt's natürlich auf YouTube immer jede Menge Comments, also Zeug, das interessiert mich
ja, aber auf der anderen Seite geht mir YouTube auf den Sack, weil so viele dumme Leute am
Start sind, übrigens heute Morgen war ich im Rewe, hab mir was vom Bäcker geholt, hab
mich draußen kurz davor gesessen und was gefuttert und da ist die Bäckerfrau dann rausgekommen
und hat sich mit der anderen Bäckerfrau drüber unterhalten, ob's Corona gibt oder nicht.
Weißt du, wenn man das immer so hört, dann denkt man sich, ja, okay, es wird schon so
Leute geben, aber eigentlich kann ich's mir nicht vorstellen und dann hast du's live
am Start, ja. Die war Querdenker. Ey, ich hab hier überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit, wenn
Leute die Maßnahmen irgendwie hinterfragen, weil das ist wirklich fragwürdig, was da
gemacht wird oder den Zusammenhang zwischen Maßnahmen und Auswirkungen, so ist ja alles
okay, aber dass man prinzipiell bezweifelt, dass es das Virus gibt oder dass es Viren
gibt, ist schon ein bisschen sehr weit hergeholt. Ja, ich bin ja immer dafür, wenn man sich
die Sachen mal genauer anguckt, aber das ist ungefähr genauso, wie wenn man bezweifelt,
dass, keine Ahnung, der Mut um die Erde kreist oder irgendwie sowas, das ist so Dinger,
das kommt ja gerade wieder auf so in letzter Zeit, aber das sind so Sachen, die kann ich
irgendwie das ernst nehmen. Ach stimmt, ja, und Bill Gates, der die Leute chippen will
und so, ja, was auch immer, aber meine Lieblingssache, wenn's um so richtig abgedrehte lustige Verschwörungstheorien
gibt, ist, dass Obamas Bodyguard Reptilienmensch ist. Also das ist meine persönliche Lieblingstheorie
in der Richtung. Warum hat der Typ so viel Splatoon Musik? Ja, den Kerl gibt's auch
noch. So, also jetzt kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache, ich muss mal kurz durch den Chat gehen,
da gab's nämlich ein paar offene Sachen. Subs hab ich hoffentlich keine übersehen.
Was hältst du davon? Moment, kann ich dir gleich sagen. Ach, das ist die Geschichte,
das halt ich persönlich für Schwachsinn. Da hatten wir's... Was zum... Was ist mit
der Seite los? Ich mein, die sah eben schon in weiß nicht gut aus, aber in grün sieht
es ja noch schlimmer aus. Das hatten wir vor ein paar Tagen schon mal. Ich halte das
für schwachsinnig. Das liegt zum größten Teil da, also die hauptsächliche Sache, dass
ich noch mal kurz sagen kann, warum ich glaube, dass da Schwachsinn ist, ist folgendes. Microsoft
müsste so viele Custom Patches pflegen für irgendwie den Lienungskernel, dass der Gramm
so funktioniert, wie's funktioniert, weil gerade der Vorteil ist, dass Windows auch
sehr viele proprietäre Binary-Plop-Driver mit aller möglichen Genüs hat, die so definitiv
niemals in den Lienungskernel kommen werden. Da müsste Microsoft quasi ein bisschen ähnlich
wie Android, bloß noch viel, viel mehr, die bräuchten einen Custom-Gepatchten Lienungskernel,
der quasi den halben Kernel umschreibt. Dann ist halt die große Preisfrage, warum sollten
sie das machen, wenn sie einfach Windows weiterverwenden können. Das ergibt für mich ehrlich gesagt
überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und eines der Argumente, die hier teilweise angeführt werden, ich
weiß nicht, ob sie das hier aufgegriffen haben, aber hier in dem Ursprungssache ist es drinne,
dass Microsoft in Azure ja mittlerweile auch schon mehr, die Musik ist mir irgendwie ein
bisschen laut. Genau, also eines der Argumente war ja, die angeführt wurden, dass Microsoft
ja in Azure mittlerweile mehr Linux betreibt als Windows. Ja, ist ja kein Wunder. Das glaube
ich sofort. Linux ist für so Server-Sachen in Azure auch einfach besser geeignet als
Windows. Und mit Linux kostet nichts, weil ich glaube nicht, dass in Azure eine Windows-Lizenz
dabei ist. Zumindest bei den Azure-Kisten, die ich bisher verwendet, war keine Windows-Lizenz
dabei. Ich habe sogar noch den Screenshot aus der Azure-Schulung, wo Windows gefragt
hat, ob man nicht aktivieren möchte. 1337, nein, das wusste ich nicht. Das wusste ich
nicht. Er schreibt, Max, hast du gewusst, dass Justin Bieber's Affe, über den du 2013
mal ein Video gemacht hast, vor zwei Jahren Mutter geworden ist? Exzellent, das ist wichtig
zu messen. So, ich glaube, ich habe den Chat durch. Ja, ich bin im Chat unten angekommen.
Fangen wir mit Proxmox gleich an, ja. Hast du Erfahrung mit GPU-Treiber auf Linux installieren?
Ne, das ist, glaube ich, fünf Jahre her, wo ich das letzte Mal gemacht habe. Ansonsten
habe ich nur Notebooks verwendet mit integriertem Intel-Treiber, da musst du nichts installieren.
Oder hier auf dem Desktop in meiner VM. So, falls ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen habe,
fange ich jetzt an. Schreib es einfach nochmal. So, erstmal ein Darkreader anmachen, dass
ich jetzt hier nicht irgendwie erblinde. Aber angeblich sind mittlerweile AMD-Treiber
auch gar nicht so übel unter Linux. Früher war es ja Nvidia-only, also Intel immer schon,
aber dann mehr oder weniger fast nur Nvidia. Und mittlerweile wohl auch halbwegs AMD. Xerox
Junio, 13 Monate, exquisite subscription, huge. Excellent. So. Hast du dir schon mal
ein Risiko, das ist die China-CPU, nein, die habe ich noch nicht angekauft. Was läuft
denn aktuell bei dir, wenn nicht Proxmox? Fragt Business Raster. Bei mir läuft mittlerweile,
ich habe ja richtig, richtig hart downgraded. Es ist gut, dass ich ein Video darüber gemacht
habe, weil da kann ich jetzt immer zeigen, wenn es darum geht. Ich hatte ja früher hier
ein bisschen Overkill installiert. So, mit alter YouTube, das geht mir in letzter Zeit
wirklich auf den Keks. Mit dieser fetten Kiste hier oben und ganz anderem Zeug. Ich
habe jetzt downgraded auf eine 2 HE-Kiste mit Low-Power-Intel-Plattform und da läuft
einfach ein stinknormales Ubuntu 18.04-Server drauf mit ein paar Dockern-Containern fertig
und eine 12TB-Platte für Fileserver. Und eine externen Platte, wo einmal nachts drauf gesynkt
wird. Also ich habe hart zurückgefahren, was man aber auch im Stromverbrauch sieht. Es
ist nicht so, dass das Wreck ultra viel verbraucht hat, aber es ist halt schon ein Unterschied,
ob du 100 Watt Idol brauchst oder nur noch 30. Oder eher 150 und jetzt 30. Wohlgemerkt
für das ganze Wreck. Was genau ist Broxmox? Sowas wie ESX, falls du das kennst. Puzzy.
Weiß nicht, ob dir das was sagt. Das ist quasi eine Plattform für Container und VMs mit
Webinterface. So ein bisschen was wie ESX. So, also, probieren wir mal. Download. Okay,
wir müssen, Achtung Leute, Sonnenbrille aufziehen. Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht? What the
fuck? Äh, das da? ISO Images, Download, jawoll. Mit VLC, alles klar. Ist immer mit VLC
öffnet. Was haben die sonst noch? Broxmox Backup Server, was ist denn das? Ach gut,
brauchen wir eh nicht. Brock Backup, beste. Falls jemand, weil ich öfters mal gefragt
wird, mit was ich Backups mache. Beste. Beste Backup Tool. Hat nicht umsonst 6600 Sterne
auf GitHub. Geht unter Windows auch, wird glaube ich offiziell nicht so porten unter
Windows, aber kein Problem, unter Windows laufen zu lassen. Es ist ein bisschen, also
es braucht ein bisschen Eingewöhnung, bis man sich da eingearbeitet hat, aber dann ist
das beste Backup Tool. Du hast Verschlüsselung, De-Duplication, Kompression, alles in einem.
Du kannst das ganze Snapshot, äh, nicht Snapshot, nicht Snapshot rotieren. Incrementell machen
dann wieder, wie heißt es? Incrementell und Full Backup, also das ist wirklich gut. Kann
ich jedem empfehlen, sich das nochmal anzugucken und ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile auch ein
halbwegs brauchbares Web-UI. Hi, kommt eigentlich ein Video auf deinem Kanal? Ja, tatsächlich.
Ähm, ob ihr mir das glaubt oder nicht. Ich habe gestern Mittag versucht, was aufzunehmen.
Allerdings zu einem, keinem Gaming-Thema und zwar, wie ihr alle wisst, Moment, äh,
wie ihr alle wisst, ist, ähm, bin ich ja mittlerweile 36, auch wenn ich, das überrascht immer viele
Leute irgendwie. Also ja, ich bin 36, sitze hier vorm Rechner und, äh, erzähle was von
Poggers und blende komische Emotes ein, aber, ich bin 36, ich bin 1984 geboren, also ich
bin so zwischen Zoomer und Boomer-Generation. Ich bin, also, wenn man es genau nimmt, eigentlich,
ich, ich mein, ich war ja relativ jung noch im Jahr 2000, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich
jetzt Doomer bin. Keine Ahnung, zumindest, zumindest bin ich ja mittlerweile 36 und ich
wollte ein Video mal dazu machen, so zu einer Sache, die ich gelernt habe mittlerweile mit
36. Und wo ich finde, wo relativ wenig dazu gesagt wird, ich will jetzt nicht großartig
rumschwätzen, ich sag noch mal kurz, ich hab's im Stream ja auch schon, ich hab's im Stream
auch schon öfters gesagt. Ähm, es gibt so oft, die, es gibt überall so Motivationssprüche,
ja, auf Twitter hauen manche Leute irgendwelche Motivations-Tweets raus, so hier in Richtung
Just Do It und sonst was oder in Videos und eines der Ratschläge, die man bei diesen
ganzen Motivations-Dingern total oft hört, ist, man soll drauf scheißen, was andere
Leute sagen. Und da hab ich ein bisschen andere Meinungen zu und dazu hab ich ein Video aufgenommen,
weil ich bin der Meinung, dass drauf scheißen, was andere Leute sagen, erstens nicht der
Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist, manchmal ist es ganz sinnvoll, was andere Leute sagen,
aber es geht ja hauptsächlich bei diesen Aussagen drum, was andere Leute über dich
sagen oder wenn andere Leute über dich irgendwie sagen, du bist kacke, ja, dass man das nicht
so, dass einem das egaler sein sollte. So, das ist halt die Aussage, die da öfters getroffen
wird und ich finde, das trifft es nicht so ganz, das ist, damit anzufangen ist bescheuert,
wenn man nicht den ersten Schritt gemacht hat. Und der erste Schritt ist meiner Meinung
nach, bevor man drauf scheißen kann, was andere Leute von einem halten, muss man erstmal
mit sich selbst halbwegs zufrieden sein, sonst klappt das nicht. Das sagt sich so einfach
so nach dem Motto, scheiß drauf, was andere sagen, aber solange du eben nicht selbst
so halbwegs mit dir zufrieden bist, wirst du es nie im Kopf auf die Reihe kriegen, drauf
zu scheißen, was andere sagen. Das heißt, der erste Schritt ist eigentlich erstmal,
dass man selbst mal so in sich geht und sich überlegt, ist man eigentlich mit sich selbst
zufrieden. Und wenn man dann mit sich selbst zufrieden ist irgendwann mal, dann ist der
zweite Schritt eigentlich total einfach und man braucht den zweiten Schritt gar nicht
bewusst zu machen, weil der zweite Schritt kommt von ganz allein. Ich meine, das heißt
jetzt nicht, dass man komplett drauf scheißen soll, wenn jetzt einer sagt, guck mal Max,
was weiß ich, die Präsentation, die du gehalten hast, war in den und den Punkten
schlecht. Okay, dann kann man dem ja zuhören. Das ist ja damit nicht gemeint. Aber wenn
man zumindest halbwegs damit zufrieden ist und sich nicht bei jedem Furz, den ein anderer
sagt, gleich in Frage stellt, was man so macht, dann ist einem das eigentlich auch egal,
dann braucht man den zweiten Schritt gar nicht mehr. Und das ist eigentlich meiner Ansicht
nach so der Schritt, den man früher oder später jeder mal machen muss, wenn er nicht im Kopf
durchdrehen muss. Also wenn du nicht irgendwie total, ja wenn du nicht mit der Zeit total
irgendwelche psychischen Probleme entwickeln willst, da ist Selbstbewusstsein. Weiß ich,
ob es das trifft. Ja, aber sowas in der Richtung. Was wovon ich auch nichts halte, ist so diese
übertriebenen, diese übertriebenen Selbstbewusstseins Kurse, die es da teilweise gibt, wo man sich,
wo sich halt Leute, die übelste Spasten sind, einreden, dass sie die größten sind. Das
ist halt auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Es ist schon nicht verkehrt, wenn man selbst
in der Lage ist zu erkennen, wenn man Scheiße macht. Also das ist auch nicht verkehrt, ja,
das ist ja damit auch nicht gemeint. Aber man sollte irgendwann mal wirklich sich Gedanken
über sich selbst machen oder so überlegen, ok, was sind denn Sachen? Das heißt auch nicht,
dass man nicht irgendwas ändern kann an dem, was man macht. Aber man muss die Sachen nicht
unbedingt nur ändern, weil jetzt das andere Leute von einem wollen, sondern das ist halt
die Frage, wenn man sagt, hey, wahrgenommen, ne, also sag mal, ihr wisst ja, ich hab's
schon öfters gesagt, ich mag tiefes Wasser nicht. Es gibt so zwei Sachen, vor denen ich
Schiss habe. Das sind einmal Spinnen und tiefes Wasser. Ja, ich weiß, das können viele Leute
nicht verstehen, aber ich hab Schiss vor tiefem Wasser. Vor allem tief, ich glaube aber,
das ist gar nicht so wenig verbreitet. Also du kannst mich weder mit Schlangen, mit Mäusen,
mit sonst was irgendwie, mit Blutkotze, sonst was, juckt mich alles nicht. Spinnen und tiefes
Wasser. So, und wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ey, ich möchte, ich kann schwimmen, klar,
ich kann sogar relativ, ok, ich geb zu, ich geh nicht mehr oft schwimmen, aber ich hat
sie alle durch, bis Goldabzeichen auf der Hose, wie ich klein war, ja. Das ist nicht
das Problem. Ich kann im Schwimmbad ohne Probleme schwimmen. Was ich überhaupt nicht mag ist
Baggersee. Also Baggersee, das krieg ich nicht hin. Da sieht man nämlich nix. Mehr, mehr
ist kein Problem, ja, aber, ähm, wie tief ist tief, eigentlich reicht mir schon, wenn
es tief tiefer ist, als dass ich mit den Füßen runterkomme und, ähm, ich nicht sehe, wie
tief es geht. Also, ich bin zum Beispiel öfters früher am Baggersee gewesen und hab mich dann
auf die Luftmatratze gelegt, hab dann ein bisschen rumgepaddelt, weil ich hab mich nicht
getraut, ähm, über den See zu schwimmen. Ich hab da permanent gedacht, da sind irgendwelche
komischen mutierten Fische drin oder sowas, frag mich nicht, man denkt sich ja die bescheuertsten
Sachen aus, wenn man Schiss vor irgendwas hat. Ja, und, deswegen, das mag ich nicht. Und
ich hab dann irgendwann gemerkt, dass wenn ich so auf der Luftmatratze rumgepaddelt bin,
dann, da guckste so ins Wasser und man sieht ja nix. Also, wenn man von der Luftmatratze
in den Baggersee reinguckt, du siehst ja nix, das spiegelt ja wie Sau. Und ich hab mir immer
eingebildet, dass unter mir irgendwelche riesigen, äh, gefährlichen Fische rum, also im Prinzip
waren das eigentlich nur Spiegelungen auf der Oberfläche, das war mir klar, da haben
sich irgendwelche Bäume drin gespiegelt und sonst was, aber ich hab dann ins Wasser runtergeguckt
von der Luftmatratze und hab gedacht, da wären irgendwelche riesen, gefährlichen Fischer
unter mir und sowas, weil ich es halt nicht gesehen hab im Wasser. Darf ich den Link posten
über den, du kannst ruhig machen, Fisch, die Fisch-KI ist am Start. Schau mal in das,
was gibt es, gibt es echt sowas? How I imagine deep water, ja, genau das, ohne Scheiß. Das,
was triffts genau, MonkaS. Exakt so stell ich mir tiefes Wasser vor. Ist ohne Scheiß,
ist so. Sieht übelst zum Fürchten aus, alter. Wahrscheinlich wirkt es auf mich jetzt so,
weil ich mich da auch besonders gut reinversetzen kann, ja. Ja. Kommt heute Teil 2 von dem hier,
weiß ich nicht, was war denn das? Moment, was ist das? Ach, das ist, wo ich schon mal
Pogsmogs ausprobiert hab. Moment, was hab ich da gemacht? What the fuck? Hä? Hä, Max,
hä? Das hab ich jetzt nicht kapiert. Was hab ich da gemacht? Hä? Ich hab mich eingeloggt
und direkt rebooted. Da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern. Ne, das waren wir
heute nicht. Naja, so. Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Wenn man jetzt quasi sagt, ich downloade
mal das aktuelle Pogsmogs, ne, in der Zwischenzeit. Wenn man sowas hat und sagt, hey, ich will
jetzt tauchen lernen oder so und sagt, ja, okay, vielleicht kann man das irgendwie überwinden,
vollkommen in Ordnung, ja. So, aber irgendwann, während das runterlädt, kann ich das mal
kurz fertig sagen, aber irgendwann muss man halt wirklich mal so in sich gehen und sich
halt überlegen, okay, manche Sachen gehören halt einfach zu ein dabei, ne. Ich hab mal
irgendwann festgestellt, dass ich andere Menschen nicht mag. So. Das hab ich aber nie bewusst
festgestellt, bis ich mir da mal Gedanken drüber gemacht hab. Zum Beispiel, warum ich
nie auf Weihnachtsfeiern gehe und sowas. Ich hasse andere Menschen, vor allem wenn
ich sie nicht kenne und die meisten, die ich kenne, mag ich auch nicht. Außer natürlich,
ihr wisst ja den Chat. Hört mal, der Chat, Chat, aus, außen vor, ja. Ähm, und das sind
so Sachen, da muss man sich erstmal selbst im Klaren drüber werden, warum man manche
Sachen macht. Ich hab mich immer davor gedrückt, auf die Weihnachtsfeier zu gehen, auf irgendwelche
Veranstaltungen zu gehen oder sonst was. Ähm, der einzige Grund, warum ich, warum ich
auf Weihnachtsfeiern gehe und sowas ist zum Essen, ja, ja. Hab ich euch schonmal erzählt,
wo ich's, auf der, auf der, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet hab, ähm, also schon
ne ganze Weile her, irgendwo 2008, 7, 8 oder so, hab ich euch mal erzählt, wo ich's da
mal, äh, zwischenmenschlich so, ähm, komplett, was heißt, absolut nicht verstanden hab und
voll verkackt hab. Weiß ich, ob ich das schonmal erzählt hab. Da. Also, da war, da war ich
ja selbst noch, da war ich ja selbst noch Azubi. Mit dem Grill, genau, Nico. Mit dem Grill
und der Bahn, ok, ich hab's schon erzählt, ich hab's schon erzählt. Ich, ich hab's schon,
ich hab's schon erzählt, ja. Zumindest, ich, für, für all die Lichter bei mir wären das
Ganze runterlädt und wir machen, wir machen, ach, ich hab's schon runtergeladen, wir machen
jetzt nebenbei noch den USB-Stick davon, ähm, und während, während der USB-Stick brennt,
dann, äh, erzähl ich's dir. Nein, nein, nicht das Weihnachtsgrill, Leute, das Weihnachtsgrill,
das ist, das ist zwei Jahre her oder ein Jahr oder so, ne, zwei, zwei. Weiß ich schon
gar nicht mehr genau. Äh, so, also, wir machen mal kurz den USB-Stick in der Zwischenzeit.
Ne, also, was ich da verkackt hab, war folgendes. Übrigens, ich zeig euch mal absolut high-end,
high-end, ähm, SSD, die ich noch gefunden hab, die wir heute zum installieren verwenden.
Warte mal. Absolut high-end, es ist. 32G SSD von vor 15 Jahren oder so. Uralt, uralt,
na, 15 Jahre nicht, von vor 10 Jahren oder so, uralt. Gab's nicht auch mal, oh, erinnere
mich nicht da dran, Sorbanjo, erinnere mich nicht da dran. Sorbanjo, das ist ein Thema,
hör mal bloß auf. Das Minecraft-Grill, das war echt problematisch. Ne, ne, ne, ne, das,
das, nein, nein, die mein ich nicht. So, hat er jetzt erkannt, dass ich die SSD angeschlossen
hab. Moment. Moment, was ist denn die, was ist denn die richtige? Ah, hier, das war doch
die richtige. Okay, wusste ich nicht, genau. So, also Flash vom File, Downloads, ähm,
genau, und während das Flash kann ich das von der Weihnachtsfeier erzählen, wo ich
das richtig schön verschissen hab. Wo ist es denn, Proxmox? Ach, okay. Ach, stimmt, bin
da bescheuert, ich hab das vorhin schon geflasht, ich muss das gar nicht, komm, wir flashen
das jetzt einfach noch mal. Eigentlich muss ich nicht flashen, ich hab das vorhin ja schon
geflasht. Egal, da kann ich jetzt wirklich was erzählen, wir flashen jetzt einfach noch
mal. Exzellent. So, und zwar auf der Weihnachtsfeier, damals, wo ich dort, wo ich noch wie gesagt
beim Provider gearbeitet hab, ähm, da gab's, äh, also wie gesagt, ich war ja noch Azubi
und wie gesagt, ich war Azubi in Frankfurt und der Provider war in einer anderen Stadt
in Deutschland, also das war eine ganze Ecke weg, aber aus diesem Grund bin ich da nicht
gerne hingefahren, aber auf die Weihnachtsfeier und so bin ich, damals hab ich mich da ab
und zu noch gezwungen und da hab ich's halt richtig verkackt und zwar gab's da auch eine
Auszubildende, die, ähm, wir haben uns eigentlich, ich würd's mal so beschreiben, wir haben
uns eigentlich von Anfang an irgendwie gemocht, ja, und ich war ja nicht oft da an diesem
Standort, aber, ähm, wenn ich denn da war, war wir da auch ab und zu Mittagessen und
sonst was, also wir haben uns eigentlich wirklich gut verstanden und man hat auch so im Nachhinein,
ja, so wenn ich mal, wenn ich mal so in mich geh, muss ich sagen, man hat das, man hat's
auch im Nachhinein irgendwie gemerkt, dass wir glaub ich beids, ups, sorry, ähm, beidseitig
ein bisschen verknallt ineinander gewesen sind. So, und an der Weihnachtsfeier, äh, Weihnachtsfeier,
keine Ahnung, hat mich nicht, irgendwie 23 Uhr, irgendwas, ähm, die Leute sind grad
angefangen ultra besoffen zu werden, da ist sie auf einmal zu mir gekommen und hat gefragt,
ähm, ob ich sie nicht heimbringen kann, beziehungsweise ob ich sie nicht zum Zug begleiten kann, ob
ich sie nicht zum Zug bringen kann, sie will nicht alleine laufen und sowas. Und ich bin
halt so richtig dämlich gewesen, ich hab's damals nicht gecheckt. Ich hab's, ich hab's
komplett, komplett nicht kapiert, ja, so richtig, richtig bescheuert. Zumindest, ähm, hab ich
dann gesagt, ja klar, kann ich machen, ja, kein, kein, kein Ding. Und, ähm, nee, viel
mehr kommt da jetzt nicht. Also, da kommt jetzt nichts ultra zum Fremdschämen, aber
ich hab's, ich hab's nur verkackt, ich hab gesagt, ja, können wir machen, ich zieh mich
schnell an. Und ich hab's damals auch schon gar nicht gecheckt, die hat schon versucht
quasi so möglichst schnell da abzuhauen, ja, und so auch, dass es kaum jemand mitkriegt.
Und, ähm, ich bin damit raus. So, und irgendwann, äh, waren wir draußen und da standen halt
noch ein paar andere Leute. Und da sind wir halt so Richtung Bahnhof gelaufen, irgendwann
sind es ja noch ein paar andere von der Firma entgegengekommen und da meinte halt noch so
einer, ja, ja, er muss jetzt auch zum Bahnhof, er kann da mit, äh, und schon gucken. Und
da hab ich dann gesagt, ja, okay, alles gut, macht's gut, ich geh ins Hotel. So richtig,
so richtig dumm, äh. Eigentlich hätt ich sagen müssen, nee, nee, natürlich bringe
ich dich noch zum Bahnhof und dann noch irgendwie bisschen schwätzen unterwegs und sagen, ja,
wollen wir vielleicht irgendwie sonst wie noch oder, äh. Aber, Massive Pains Champ.
Richtig verkackt. Also im Nachhinein betrachtet war das eigentlich alles sehr offensichtlich,
aber der Max hat's nicht verstanden. So, hat das jetzt, hat das Ganze jetzt eigentlich
fertig gebrannt, äh, gebrannt, Alter. Ihr seht aber, wie mich so themisch schon wieder
verwirren, äh, eigentlich gebrannt, geflasht. Chat, wie lang ist es her, dass ihr zuletzt
was gebrannt habt? Mentosbfh sagt, du warst kurz vor den Newcomestern von der Web gesprungen.
So könnte man's umschreiben, ja. Paar Jahre, ok. Übrigens, jetzt wo ich euch da grad frag,
was hab. Was geht mit der Musik ab? Ähm, wo wir grad beim Thema sind, ich hab euch
ja grad gefragt, weil ich zuletzt ein CD gebrannt hab. Wann hab ich euch denn eigentlich zuletzt
schon mal meine Heizungsüberwachung gezeigt und wie gut die funktioniert? Ich glaube,
das ist schon ne ganze Weile her. Man sieht hier auch wieder, wie schön man unten erkennt,
wie die Pumpe läuft, wie der Brenner angeht und die Heizungstemperatur im Durchschnitt,
Abgas, Kessel, Status. Ich glaub, das ist bestimmt schon zwei Jahre her, wo ich euch
das gezeigt hab, oder? Merci für mal, Alter. Hast du sie danach überhaupt wieder gesehen?
Ja, ja und ne, also nur mal kurz. Und ich hab's, wie gesagt, ich hab's erst mal überhaupt
nicht gecheckt und danach hab ich's eigentlich auch weiter verkackt und leider war die mit
ihrer Ausbildung mehr oder weniger, fragt mich nicht, März oder so dann fertig. Und
ich wollte sie noch am letzten Tag anrufen. Ich wollte sie noch am letzten Tag anrufen,
als ich die Mail gesehen hab, ich hab die Mail gesehen, irgendwie so ne Abschluss-Mail,
so nach dem Motto hat ihre Ausbildung beendet und als ich die Mail gesehen hab, wollte ich
instant anrufen und auch fragen, keine Ahnung, ne Handynummer, falls ich mal wieder da bin
oder irgendwas in der Richtung, keine Ahnung. Weil das war so die letzte Chance, die ich
hätte nutzen können und ja und dann war's Telefon schon abgemeldet. Pepehands. Ne,
also da ist nichts mehr passiert danach. Eigentlich richtig dämlich. So, ähm, muss der SSD abziehen.
F, ja. So, jetzt stöpseln wir mal diese High-End-SSD. Leute, die SSD ist übel schwer. Ich weiß
nicht, ob die damals noch irgendwie 5-fach-Layer-Flash reingemacht haben oder so. Kann man überhaupt
von der SSD installieren mit so nem USB-Adapter? Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert. Probieren wir
jetzt mal aus. Stöpseln wir mal kurz dran. Ah ja, und dann muss ich, oh fuck, ich hab
meine Tastatur wieder, den Knopf abgemacht. Ich hab ihn immer noch, ich hab ihn immer
immer noch festgeklebt. Dann müssen wir mal kurz GameCapture-HD aufmachen und gucken,
ob die Verbindung zu der Kiste da oben in der Ecke funktioniert. Warte mal, checken wir
grad mal schnell. Ach, ich war mal kurz dran.
Ah, yes. Exzellent. Okay, das funktioniert. Jetzt muss ich bloß noch die SSD dran sch-
Was macht der da grade? Sollte der jetzt nicht einfach nur anzeigen, äh, keine Platte gefunden
oder sowas? Teddy Kupp fragt, ich will mir ein eigenes NAS bauen. FreeNAS oder OpenMediaVault?
Ganz ehrlich, nachdem ich das gestern ausprobiert hat, nehme das hier. Beste. Hat mir um, also
OpenMediaVault hat mir gar nicht gefallen, FreeNAS ist ganz okay, hat mir um Längen
besser gefallen als alles andere. Das ist das Synology Betriebssystem, was du aber selbst
auf deiner, auf deiner eigenen Hardware installieren kannst. Also, ich bin ja selten begeistert
von irgendwas, aber da muss ich echt sagen, vom Funktionsumfang her und auch wie einheitlich
das Ganze zu bedienen ist, würde ich, kann ich, kann ich das nur jedem halbwegs versierten
Selbstbastler empfehlen, sich den Kram draufzuhauen. Ob das jetzt so zuverlässig ist wie ein FreeNAS
mit ZFS, wenn du da spezielle Anforderungen hast, sei mal dahingestellt, aber wenn du
kein ZFS haben willst, nehme das hier. Da hast du auch alles, was du brauchst, eingebaut
von irgendwelchen Fotoverwaltungen, Notizverwaltungen, IP-CAM Geschichten, also falls du das brauchen
sollst, wenn nicht, lässt es aus, zig Zusatzregeln, kannst Docker, Container, VMs, alles mögliche
über die GUI drauf laufen lassen. Wenn es dich interessiert, was man damit machen kann,
kannst du das zum ersten Mal im Stream ausprobieren, kannst du dir mal angucken. Also, ich muss
echt sagen, von allen NAS-Systemen, die ich bisher ausprobiert habe, ist das mit Abstand
das Beste. Also die Cyanology-Jungs wissen, was sie machen. So, jetzt mal hier, ne, der
mag nicht booten, was hat der denn für Schmerzen. Ich mach mal die SSD dran und gucke, ob er
bootet. Achtung, leakt, Leute, leakt. Passt nicht. Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah,
ah, ah. Äh, ach so, jetzt muss ich mal erstmal neu starten. Mal gucken, ob mein Hetzer-Kabel
reicht. Moment, Moment. Netzteil aus oder Netzteil wieder an. Dash Player, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön! Ich bin gerade nicht am Rechnen, sonst würde ich irgendwelche Sounds einspielen.
Danke schön für den Sub, ich muss erst mal ins Netzteil dran
Netzteil
So
Gucken ob es jetzt bootet
Wenn nicht muss ich die Tastatur dranstecken und Bootmenü auswählen
Auf geht's
Was Proxmox 6.2 da startet die Zertifizierung nur im...
Ah, da ist es doch! Exzellent
Achso, ja gut, die Tastatur muss ich jetzt trotzdem anschließen
Kann man in Xpnology auch einen J-Downloader? Klar
Du kannst ja ein vollständiges, du kannst ja eine vollständige Shell holen
Also J-Downloader selbst habe ich nicht nachgeschaut
Ich habe aber gesehen, dass es im Community-Repo Custom Addons gibt für Downloader
Von Torrent bis sonst was, aber J-Downloader bestimmt auch
Am ansonsten kannst du es garantiert irgendwie nachinstallieren
Und spätestens, dass du Docker-Container laufen lassen kannst
Kannst du eh alles drinne machen, was du willst
Ähm, so
Ich mache mal hier fullscreen, dass man ordentlich was sieht
So, und jetzt muss ich die Tastatur umstöpseln
Moment, Tastatur umstöpseln
Achso
Alter, warum steckt man USB immer falsch rum rein?
oral
Ah, kennt ihr das? USB ist prinzipiell falsch rum.
Max, hol dir doch ein KVM-Spider, hab ich. Hab ich sogar.
Ahem, hab ich. Ich weiß bloß grad nicht wo. Hab ich.
Damit kann man über den Browser die Sache fernsteuern.
Hab ich. Ok, gucken ob das steuern jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, passt. Install.
Windows 10 über SSH zu bedienen ist grausam, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Man konnte da Gesicht im Finger nach...
Der war gut.
So, also Installer.
Ok. Ah, Moment, brauche ich jetzt wirklich die Maus dafür?
Ich hoffe nicht. Das geht doch bestimmt auch so.
Brauche ich da die Maus für?
Ich komm nicht auf das Agree. Ich brauch da die Maus für, oder?
Also Tab geht nicht und Alt-Tab geht nicht.
Also, weder noch. Ok, dann hole ich meine Maus.
Also Mäuse hab ich genug, bloß Tastatur nicht.
Hab ich. Häuser hab ich doch, kein Problem.
Was, es gibt eine Spezial... Ok, na gut, jetzt zu spät.
Oh, die Maus ist übelst verstaubt und klebt. Die lag ewig rum.
Ok. Wir agreeen, Excel. So und jetzt kann ich bestimmt mit Tastatur machen, hä?
Ach, jetzt. Das ist ja bescheuert, warum kann ich denn jetzt mit Tastatur bedienen?
Aber vorher nicht. Das ist doch doof.
Kann die Kamera eigentlich umfallen und ich liegen? Sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass die einfach umfällt.
Ok, wahrscheinlich muss ich hier einfach jetzt einen Beitrag machen, hä?
Germany, jawoll. Warum lassen die mich das am Anfang denn nur mit der Maus klicken?
Und jetzt mit der Tastatur, das ist irgendwie auch ein bisschen widersprüchlich.
Passwort. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Mail at example.invalid. Exzellent. Perfekt. Woher kennen die meine E-Mail-Adresse?
Mail at...
Ey, wir machen das anders.
example.com ist schon ok.
www.example.com. Und wir können auch local aus... Aber example.com ist ok.
example.com ist per fc-test-domain, da geht nichts.
So, also pve-example.fqdn. Ja, das ist ok, wieder fqdn heißt es mir.
Wahrscheinlich darf ich da aber nicht, Punkt example.
Ok, dann machen wir pve-punkt. Nehmen wir mal die legit-domain.
Gateway, alles klar. DNS-Server, alles klar. Next.
Wenn die Kamera umfällt, springe ich oder man schreibt dich, dann sieht mich keiner.
Insta... Und wenn man mich sieht, es gibt Schlimmeres.
Ich will plus, dass ich nicht groß irgendwo zeigen, weil ich keinen Bock habe, dass...
Was geht mit der Maus ab?
Dass mich irgendwelche Leute im Zug erkennen oder so, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Es gab schon Events, wo mich Leute gefilmt haben, bis auf wenige gecheckt, dass ich das bin.
Also es ist nicht schlimm, das haben dann so wenige...
Cobol Stream an Weihnachten.
So, mal gucken, wie lange der hier installiert.
Wir müssen ihm ja gar nicht zugucken.
Was erzählt er uns hier eigentlich?
Proxmox Cluster Filesystem PMXCFS.
Also einen kryptischeren Namen hätten wir ja nicht mal verwenden können.
Das ist übrigens eine Sache, die wir später ausprobieren werden.
Angeblich, also Proxmox kann ja nur direkt, quasi raw LXC-Virtualisierung,
aber angeblich kann man mittlerweile da drin auch einen Docker laufen lassen.
Mal ausprobieren, wie gut das funktioniert.
Natürlich kann man immer noch eine VM installieren und darin einen Docker laufen lassen.
Das ist ja keine Frage, das geht natürlich auch.
So, bla bla bla bla, juckt uns alles nicht.
Pascal Stream.
Naja, also wir programmieren öfter C-Sharp und in C-Sharp steckt ein bisschen Pascal drin.
Aber allein schon, weil der Pascal, Moment, bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander, Pascal oder Delphi?
Weil der C-Sharp Erfinder hat vorher Delphi oder Pascal entwickelt.
Ich bin jetzt gar nicht sicher ob es Pascal oder Delphi, ich glaube Delphi war es, oder?
Wo hat der Heilsberg mit dran entwickelt, Delphi?
Delphi ist Pascal, ja stimmt, deswegen bringe ich es durcheinander.
Ich habe jetzt sicher die Tastatur dran.
Wie gesagt, der Anders Heilsberg ist ja der C-Sharp Erfinder und der hat vorher, glaube ich, entweder Pascal, Turbo Pascal, Delphi, irgendwie sowas gemacht.
Und da sind bestimmt ein paar Sachen von auch in C-Sharp mit eingeflossen.
VM in der VM ist nicht so nice.
Naja, es ist nicht VM in der VM, es wäre ja dann quasi eine VM auf Metal, also auf der Hardware hier.
Und da drin ein Docker, also das sollte sich in Grenzen halten, was man da an CPU-Leistung verliert.
Generell muss man ja sagen, die CPU-Verlust, also die CPU-Leistung, die man verliert mit Virtualisierung, halten sich in Grenzen.
Also es macht kaum einen Unterschied, ob ich jetzt was auf dem Host, also rein CPU-Leistung, ja?
Also wenn ich jetzt mal irgendwelche Prim-Zahlen berechne, lasse ich irgendwas oder Prime 95 laufen lassen oder so.
Also rein die CPU-Leistung zwischen der VM und dem Host, das ist gar kein so großer Unterschied.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie viel es ist, aber mich würde es wundern, wenn es mehr als 5% sind, die man einboosten hat.
Wahrscheinlich ist es mittlerweile bei modernen CPUs mit Virtualisierungs-Extension sowas wahrscheinlich unter 1%,
was man an CPU-Leistung einbüßt bei richtigen VMs.
Die Sache ist nur die, was übrigens meine Maus leckt übelst, weil meine Capture Card leckt.
141, also was brauchen wir? 141 8006, okay.
Alles klar, gehen wir gleich hin.
Ja.
Was? 141 8006.
Was macht hier das Proxbox-Wiki auf? Dort findet man das freie Debian-Repository für Proxbox.
Sonst erhält man keinerlei Updates über Upget. Ach.
Warum? Weil man das Subscription kaufen soll oder weil Bug?
Bootet er jetzt?
Hat er jetzt gebootet und ich sehe es bloß nicht oder?
Oder was macht er? Macht er überhaupt was?
Habt ihr gesehen, ob der gebootet hat?
Das Ding Subscription, okay.
Ich mach mal kurz Game Capture aus.
Und machs nochmal an.
Ah, da sind wir doch.
Sehr gut.
Okay, hab ich jetzt die SSD installiert und jetzt ist die SSD verreckt oder wie?
Das wärs jetzt mal.
SSD installiert, SSD direkt verreckt.
F.
Das kann ich mir jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen.
Na gut, also 1418600, ich mach mal kurz meine Tastatur wieder ab und dann gucken wir uns das Ganze an.
Finger League. Jaja, der Max hat dicke Arme und dicke Finger und so.
Das war ja auch mal eine Zeit lang so der Running Gag auf YouTube.
Dicht hinterwand zeigt die Silvana ihre Titten.
Ja, wir hatten schon viel dummes Zeug da auf YouTube, war auch geil irgendwo.
So.
Also, wo müssen wir hin? 192168.2.141 und dann 8006.
Ah, HTTPS.
Lul.
Jaja, kein gültiges Zertifikat, das hab ich mir schon fast gedacht.
Okay, Username.
Okay, Proxmox, Default.
Ach nee, Moment, ich hab doch Passwort vergeben, 123456.
Ich hab's nur vergessen, weil ich grad für Passwort eingetippt hab.
Da sind wir noch schon.
You do not have a valid subscription.
Leute, hab ich euch schon erzählt, dass man auf Twitch mit Amazon Prime total einfach eine valid bekommt.
Man kann nämlich einmal im Monat mit Amazon Prime kostenlos einen Streamer seiner Wahl Prime subscriben.
Kostet euch überhaupt gar nichts.
Ja, und hier müsst ihr eine Lizenz kaufen.
Okay, dann doch lieber Twitch Prime machen.
You do not have a valid subscription, okay.
Also das heißt, Wikiproxmox. Und nach was hat...
Irgendjemand im Chat hat grad gesagt, nach was ich gucken soll.
Ach hier, Package Report.
Crash Fluffy, drei Monate in die Abo-Fahle.
Exzellent, Dankeschön.
No subscription report.
This repository for testing and non-production.
Das ist mal sowas von kein production use, was ich hier mache.
Das Kind Ikaros Musik? Nee, Smash, fast.
Nee, eigentlich gar nicht.
So, also. So, wie ändere ich das jetzt?
Also, wie gesagt, ich hab das noch nie wirklich als Hauptsystem verwendet.
Das heißt, ich kenne mich damit nicht wirklich gut aus.
Also, wo könnte man hier jetzt Package Updates eintragen? Options, hm?
Kennt jemand Icinga? Das ist Nagios.
Ich mag, ich persönlich mag Nagios.
Aber viele andere mögen Nagios nicht.
Shell. Aha. Kann man da rein copy-pasten? Oh, nee.
Wie macht man SSH an? Hier kann man nicht copy-pasten, oder?
MonkaS, no copy-paste.
So, wir gehen jetzt erst mal kurz auf Linux und machen das unter Linux.
So, weil ich habe keinen Bock, das unter Windows zu machen.
Gut. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Bäm.
Gut. Ist SSH standardmäßig schon an? Gucken wir mal.
Gut, add.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Wir machen jetzt die easy Variante.
What?
Äh.
Ich meine, ich kann den Key löschen, aber...
What?
Warum?
Wisst ihr was? Ich lösche einfach das komplette File, weil ich brauche den ganzen bis hier nicht.
So. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Da sind wir. Sehr schön.
So, und jetzt Update geht so nicht.
Ach, tatsächlich. Update geht so nicht.
Ja, ich habe schon einen Eintrag, aber ich habe gesagt, kein Housekey-Checking. Das sollte ihn dann eigentlich nicht jucken.
Okay, ich darf wirklich nicht drauf zugreifen. So, das heißt, ich gehe jetzt ETC, Abt.
Und dann, wo gehen wir hin, dass man die Repos eintragen kann?
Äh, machen wir hier zu. Package, Repos. Erst mal kurz umkopieren auf mal Linux.
Ähm.
Abt-Sources-List.
Kein Wim drauf.
Okay, aber wie Ei. Wie Ei ist überall drauf.
So, schmeißen wir den Kram raus.
Und nu, das da.
Hä? Moment, das stand da doch schon drinnen.
Ah, die... Ach, das Einzige. Das Einzige ist das da, was man eintragen muss.
Der Rest kann da drin stehen bleiben. Lull.
So.
Okay, jetzt Abt-Update.
Unauthorized.
Reboot? Nee.
Meinst du?
Ein Reboot muss man da normalerweise nicht für machen.
Wir machen jetzt erst mal das Wichtigste. Wir installieren uns in Wim nach.
Ich meine, das ist ja unter der Haube ein Stück normales Debian.
Ach so, ja, es kann sein, dass die Alten noch hier drunter stehen.
Etc, Abt-Sources-List.
Ah, guck mal, die stehen noch hier drin. Die muss man wahrscheinlich rausmachen.
Guckt, und jetzt funktioniert's.
So, kann man die Updates über das Web-Interface machen? Das ist jetzt das nächste.
Erst mal, nicht spoilern, Chat.
Also, als Erstes, ich will mal die Schrift ein bisschen größer machen.
Siehst ja kaum was.
Aber jetzt ist viel zu fett.
So, Updates, hier.
Okay, das kann man übrigens schön über die Oberfläche machen.
Exzellent.
Also, das ist quasi mehr oder weniger ein Webfrontend für Abt-Upgrade.
Hä?
What the fuck? Was ist das?
Ach, das macht mir einen Remote, das macht mir eine VNC.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Das macht mir eine Shell auf, dass ich dem Upgrade zugucken kann, okay.
Über was hat der? XtermJS Spice? Spice hab ich nicht installiert.
Aber Spice kann ich installieren.
Dazu brauchen wir den WirtViewer.
Das weiß ich, seit ich da mal ewig gesucht hab, was man dafür...
Oh man, ich müsste jetzt auch noch Betriebssystem-Updates machen.
Da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Ne, das lassen wir jetzt.
Aber wir lassen den mal im Hintergrund updaten.
So, was hat der noch?
No, no VNC, können wir anmachen?
Okay, dann machen wir es lieber da drüber.
Hä?
It's locked by another process.
Warum?
Wie, it's locked.
Okay, das funkt ja schon funkt.
Geht schon mal gut los.
Ach so, man kann...
Ne, dann macht er die Shell auf.
Ach, jetzt funktioniert es.
Okay, yes, alles klar.
Mach Update.
Das hätten wir auch direkt...
Oh, jetzt hat es mich verwirrt.
Das sind Updates von meinem Manjaro und das sind Updates von Proxmox.
Auf geht's Proxmox, gib Gas.
Die Kiste oben rechts übrigens ist nichts sonderlich Dolles.
Das ist ein Dual Core Low Power Celeron.
Also, da muss man jetzt nicht die wahnsinnige ultra krasse Leistung von erwarten.
So, während es hier upgradet, können wir uns mal angucken, was da sonst noch ist.
So, Syslog kann man sich angucken, das ist relativ uninteressant.
Außer, dass die SSD irgendwie kaputt ist.
Time?
Ja, stimmt.
Host-Einträge.
Wirkt mir jetzt ein bisschen raw, dass man da einfach einen Texteditor hingeschmissen
kriegt, aber okay.
DNS-Server, alles klar, richtig.
Zertifikate.
Ach, hier kann man...
Das ist die Let's Encrypt Geschichte.
Wie bediene ich das jetzt?
Wo würde ich denn da jetzt, wo würde ich da jetzt beispielsweise meine Cloudflare Sachen hinterlegen?
Gibt kein Plugin.
This field is required, aber man kann nichts auswählen.
Excellent.
Vielleicht muss ich einen Account anlegen.
Name lulw.
E-Mail-Adresse lulw.
Dann muss ich da registrieren?
Ich musste mich noch nie registrieren bei Let's Encrypt.
Man muss da eine E-Mail-Adresse angeben.
Und selbst das kann man skippen.
Und alles gut?
Okay, das braucht weitere Investigation.
So, jetzt müssen wir Rebooten.
Wie Rebootet man über die Oberfläche?
Wir haben ein Update gemacht und jetzt wollen wir Rebooten.
Ich meine, klar, ich kann es über die Shell machen.
Aber es gibt doch bestimmt einen Reboot-Knopf.
Ach, hier oben, Reboot.
Excellent.
Zack.
Yes.
Ich kann mir hier zugucken, wie er Rebootet.
Und ich glaube, die SSD ist echt kaputt jetzt.
Ein Leib Bumms da.
Die SSD hat wirklich installiert und jetzt ist sie im Arsch.
Jetzt können wir ihm auch mal mal Booten zugucken.
What?
Oh, ich habe schon gedacht, der hängt jetzt in der Boot-Loop
oder so und ist kaputt.
Nee, ist er nicht.
Hat funktioniert, er ist wieder da.
Da ist er.
Zusammenfassung, Proxmox, wir haben gerade erst fertig installiert.
Und ich habe Updates gemacht, sonst nichts.
So, Disks.
Jetzt probieren wir mal, ob ich die zweite SSD irgendwie
eingehängt kriege als was auch immer zum Testen.
Initialize Disk fürs GPT, alles klar, machen wir.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Ernsthaft?
Ist die SSD gerade verreckt nach der Installation?
Es sieht echt so aus, die hat die Installation noch gemacht
und jetzt ist es kaputt.
Geil.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich meine, wir können auch von Hand das Ganze überschreiben.
Ich will mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Create ZFS.
Ist das nicht so, dass es standardmäßig ZFS ist?
Was? 16 Gigabyte ist nur frei?
Moment, what?
Der will mir doch nicht erzählen, dass er so viel für das System braucht.
Ach, der teilt das auf.
Okay, zeige ich mal her.
Route 55.
Ja, aber wo ist der Rest?
Wo ist der Rest?
Route hat 55.
Was ist SDA?
Ach so, das sehe ich bloß an der Stelle wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oh, wie das Platoon Musik.
So, dann machen wir jetzt mal was anderes.
Also wenn er wirklich der Meinung ist, meine zweite SSD...
What the fuck?
Ich glaube das nicht, dass die SSD unmittelbar nach der Installation verreckt ist.
Das glaube ich ihm nicht.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das wäre jetzt der Zufall, wäre zu groß.
Ich stöpsel es ab und mache es nochmal dran.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Hier, machen wir nochmal ab.
Eine ruhige SP-Anschluss wieder dran.
Das glaube ich ihm nicht, dass die SSD verreckt ist.
Ah, jetzt ist sie da.
Guck, easy.
Jetzt geht alles.
Hast wohl einmal zu oft geflasht, ja.
So, Usage Partitions.
Wie kann ich die jetzt verwenden als...
Als Storage?
Was ist denn überhaupt drauf?
Hat er das schon gemountet irgendwo?
Nee.
Achso, das ist das Installations-Medium, genau.
The Yenna hat...
Ach nee, du hast ein Timeout gekriegt.
Exzellent.
Wie kann ich dem jetzt sagen, dass ich das als Storage verwenden will für irgendwas?
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Rechts?
Scheint komplizierter zu sein, als ich mir das vorstelle.
Jetzt timeouten sie sich alle, reload.
Hä?
Wie sage ich ihm, dass ich die Disk verwende?
Timeout ist real im Chat, Alter.
Exquisite Timeout.
Okay, ich bin zu blöd dafür, dem zu sagen, dass er die Festplatte verwenden soll.
What the fuck?
Gut, dann ignorieren wir das jetzt mal.
Wir testen jetzt mal das eigentlich Wichtige.
Wir legen eine VM an und dann probieren wir mal das Neue aus, nämlich einen Docker laufen lassen im LXC.
Und dann gucken wir, wie das mit pass-through ist mit der 10-Gigabit-Karte.
Also falls irgendjemand noch eine Ahnung hat, wie ich den überreden kann, meine 32G SSD zu verwenden, dann sag Bescheid.
Du kriegst so einen Timeout, wenn du selbst Timeout für Points gemacht hast.
Oder wenn sich der Mod verklickt hat, weil sich gerade 30.000 Leute getimeoutet haben.
Welcher Mod ist gerade da und timeoutet?
Es ist ja toll, dass die Leute hier Punkte für Timeout ausgeben.
Exzellent.
So, also jetzt legen wir mal eine VM an.
Nodes braucht keiner.
KegW.
Exzellent, nur nicht mal Markdown, null.
Das mit dem Timeout geht übrigens nur, wenn ein Mod da ist.
Also legen wir mal eine VM an.
Storage.
Ach, hier kann man das wahrscheinlich auswählen.
Ne.
Ok, dann plege ich es nicht.
Also wir erstellen mal...
Also ok, man kann eine Firmware-Container erstellen.
Wir erstellen einfach mal eine VM.
Du hast ganz easy.
Name, Ubuntu, VM.
So, Resource Pool.
Pool.
Ne.
Ach ne, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur, wenn man irgendwie was Restriktion machen will, denke ich mal.
OS.
Oh, das enttäuscht mich jetzt ein bisschen, dass der nicht direkt ISOs downloaden kann.
Kannst auch Templates verwenden.
Wo gibt es Templates?
Ok, die Playlist geht mir voll auf den Kekse.
Da ist zu viel Splatoon Musik drinnen.
Lul, ARMS.
ARMS ist auch so eine Totgeburt von Nintendo gewesen.
Die haben ja sogar angekündigt, dass es eine ARMS eSport League gibt.
Und, ähm, gab es nie.
Ok, dann installieren wir jetzt mal eine VM.
Ich weiß, ich will ja auch eine KVM-VM erstellen.
Ich dachte aber, der kann vielleicht ISOs downloaden.
Das wäre mal richtig gut gewesen.
Das wäre einfacher gewesen.
Aber guck mal, ich habe eine Idee.
Wir können ja PXE starten.
Ich habe ein PXE bei mir am Start.
Do not use any media.
Mal gucken, ob das mit PXE funktioniert.
Next.
Ja, ja, passt alles.
Default.
Hard Drive.
Wir lassen mal alles.
Alles Default.
Next.
CPU.
Eins.
Ja, passt.
Memory ist auch ok.
Das Ding hat übrigens, das System hat übrigens kaum Speicher, ne?
Das ist übel slow-end.
Äh.
Ah na, ok, 8G.
Ist doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Das Interface sieht aber genauso aus wie beim Cyanology.
Ich dachte aber, nee, finde ich nicht.
Cyanology sah viel bunter und, ähm, äh, bisschen verspielter aus, so als das.
Was ist heute Thema Ziel?
Das einfach das neue Proxmox angucken.
Next.
Network.
Network Bridge.
Wunderbar.
Ich hoffe, das geht damit.
Dass ich, äh, müsste eigentlich gehen.
Dass ich direkt ans Netzwerk komm und PXE boot machen kann.
Confirm.
So, jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Macht er standardmäßig EFI oder BIOS?
Data Center Storage Add Directory.
Ja, das, äh, dann sagt er mir aber, dass keine Disk frei ist.
Das hab ich schon ausprobiert.
So.
Jetzt hab ich eine VM angelegt.
Wo stehen die VMs jetzt drin?
Äh.
Moment, wo find ich meine VMs?
Ach, da.
Okay, kapiert.
So, und jetzt muss ich gucken, ob das BIOS oder, äh, oder EFI ist.
Weil EFI kann ich keinen PXE boot machen.
Wobei, wir probieren's einfach raus.
So, Hardware.
BIOS.
Exzellent.
Start.
Console.
Da sind wir.
Kann man nämlich direkt EFI boot machen.
Muss ich gar kein ISO downloaden oder sowas.
Ist diese Frage sinnlos?
Nein, diese Frage ist.
Exzellent.
Kann man Vollbild machen?
Console.
Spice.
Warum kann ich kein Spice machen?
Durch das extern öffnen kann man eigentlich auch ganz praktisch.
Du wartest immer noch auf den PXE Stream.
Der PXE Stream ist ziemlich, äh, äh, kurz, ne.
Ich, ich starte einen Container und gut ist.
Also das ist total easy.
Du musst einfach den hier nehmen.
Okay, ich mach, gleich, gleich mach ich die andere Playlist.
Der Typ hat ja jedes zweite Lied irgendeine Splatoon Werbe, äh, Splatoon Musik.
Du nimmst einfach den Container, startest den und schon geht PXE boot.
Ach so, ähm, eins musst du noch machen.
Du musst den Server, auf dem du die Container laufen hast, in deinem DHCP eintragen als
Next Server.
Das ist aber auch alles, mehr musst du nicht machen.
So, äh, Linux installs.
Und zwar ein Ubuntu install, jawoll.
Komm mal her, das geht ja richtig flott heute.
Der deutsche Mirror hat, äh, Busy, Busy zugelegt, ja.
Letztes Mal war der, war der deutsche Ubuntu Mirror so unglaublich langsam.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt, das zu installieren.
Ich würde jetzt eigentlich lieber die Docker Geschichte, wir können das, wir können das
nebenbei laufen lassen.
Was, was Vollbild, ah, das ist eine VNC.
Okay, das ist also das Standard, das Standard VNC Ding.
Okay, wir sind Freedom, alles klar.
PXE boot geht nur, wenn man den DHCP Server kontrolliert, ja.
Also, du musst im PXE, du musst im DHCP den, ähm, PXE Server als Next Server eintragen,
sonst geht das nicht.
Yes, wir haben ein Ö-Key, alles klar, wir haben kein E-Key.
Wir haben German No-Dead-Keys, jawoll.
So, und während das läuft, machen wir, machen wir uns schonmal einen, äh, Container, weil
angeblich kann man mittlerweile, äh, Docker im LXC-Container von Proxmox laufen lassen.
So, Test-VM.
Ein DHCP Proxy kannst du auch machen, ja, wobei, wenn du das alles machst, ist halt die Frage,
warum du das machen kannst, aber keinen Zugriff auf den DHCP hast.
Kann man von dem PXE Server auch Windows booten?
Ja, kann man machen.
Du musst bloß einen, also ich hab's noch nicht gemacht, aber es ist eingebaut.
Ich glaub, du musst einen Windows-ISO entpacken auf dem PXE Server, weil die das sonst nicht
direkt können.
Irgendwie so.
So, ok, während der Kram jetzt installiert, machen wir das hier mal wieder zu.
Und dann legen wir mal hier einen Container an.
Kann man da, warte mal, ich mach mal kurz.
What?
Was war das denn?
Your tab has crashed.
Alles klar, ach, weil ich im Hintergrund Update mache wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das ist, weil ich im Hintergrund Update mache.
Na gut, dann muss das Tab jetzt funktionieren solange.
So, also, jetzt können wir einen Container anlegen.
Was haben die hier denn zur Auswahl?
Hostname, Omega, Lul.
Resource Pool, brauchen wir ein Passwort, 123456.
SSH Public Key, brauchen wir eine Template.
Storage.
Ok, ich muss eine Template auswählen, aber es gibt keine vorinstallierten Templates?
Du musst zuerst Templates runterladen, ok, mach ich.
Name von neuer User, Max.
Jawoll.
123456, wir machen überall nur die besten Passwörter.
Ok, andere Playlist.
Der Typ hat mir zu viel Splatoon Musik drin, da krieg ich Anfälle.
Das halt ich auf die Dauer wirklich nicht aus.
Calm and happy Nintendo Music.
Excellent.
So, sehr gut.
Das Passwort ist doch gut, das ist doch nicht weak.
Correct Time Zone, yes.
Ok, während er jetzt installiert, gucken wir, wo wir uns Templates runterladen müssen.
Ich glaube, ich muss noch zweimal OK drücken im Installer, bis er anfängt.
Ich muss ihm sagen, dass er All Disks verwenden soll, genau.
Und dann fängt er, glaube ich, jetzt an runterzuladen.
Sollte er zumindest.
Die wollten bestimmt Splatoon auch mal pushen.
Das kann schon sein, ja.
Aber es war ein bisschen viel.
Ein bisschen viel Splatoon.
Ich mein, mag ja sein, dass die Musik nicht schlecht ist.
Mein Fall ist die Splatoon Musik wirklich nicht.
Ok, jetzt können wir was anderes machen.
Jede zweite Song, Splatoon muss ja echt nett sein.
Ok, also wo lädt man jetzt hier irgendwelche Templates runter?
Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich finde es cool, was man damit alles machen kann.
Aber ich finde, die Übersichtigkeit ist jetzt erstmal nicht direkt da.
Das muss nicht schlecht sein, solange man das eine Weile verwendet und sich gut dran gewöhnt ist.
Alles in Ordnung.
Wo lade ich Templates runter?
Kann man hier oben suchen?
Template.
Wo lade ich Templates runter?
Was auf Local und dann Content?
Ach du Scheiße, da hätte ich jetzt ewig gesucht, Chat.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem und dem?
Ach, das hier ist für Isos und das hier ist für VMs, hä?
Template.
Muss ich jetzt auswählen, was ich haben will?
Gibt es da ein Alpine oder sowas?
Ja, perfekt.
Ok, man kann auch nur eins downloaden.
Ok.
Ja, die Ausgabe könnte ein bisschen schöner sein, aber da will ich mich jetzt mal nicht drüber beschweren.
Task finished, ok.
Templates, Alpine haben wir.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch irgendein neues Ubuntu.
Einfach weil es geht.
Download.
Chat, hat irgendeiner von euch das hauptsächlich im Einsatz bei euch?
Nutz du Kaddi aktiv, ist das möglich in Kaddi 2 Reverse Proxy Storm?
Klar.
Ach so, geht doch weiter.
Einmal einer, der nur auf AP reagiert und der andere soll andere anfangen.
Ja, klar, das geht.
Also Kaddi 2 habe ich nicht, das liegt aber daran, dass das schon eine Weile läuft.
Aber mit Kaddi 1 geht das.
Also sind das jetzt unprivilegierte LXC Container?
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie der das startet.
C2HO sagt, ich hatte Proxmox laufen, hatte aber alle 14 Tage einen Crash und alles weggeflogen, ok.
Aber die meisten im Chat sind zufrieden.
Kann Proxmox keine Docker Container starten?
Nicht direkt, das ist genau das, was ich jetzt ausprobieren will.
Nämlich angeblich kann man mittlerweile einen Proxmox Container starten und in dem Docker starten.
Was vollkommen ok ist, weil Container in Container ist quasi kein Unterschied zu Container in Haus starten.
Also das ist nicht so wie nested Virtualisierung, wo es wirklich Leistung frisst.
Bei Container macht es eigentlich keinen Unterschied, ob ich Container in Container in Container starte.
Weil, ich habe es ja schon oft genug gesagt, Linux Container im Prinzip gar keine Container.
Das Container ist so ein scheiß Wort dafür.
Es ist eigentlich nur ein weiterer Prozess mit ein bisschen Sandbox drum herum.
Also ob du jetzt den Prozess auf dem Haus direkt startest oder in einem Container macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Außer, dass der Container selbst ein bisschen mehr Sandbox drum herum hat.
Also es sagen zwar alle, man kann Container nicht mit VMs vergleichen, aber machen es dann doch irgendwie.
Und deswegen finde ich das Wort Container nicht so richtig passen.
Ich weiß nicht, ganz ehrlich, vielleicht hätte man es besser Sandbox nennen sollen.
Wann machen wir eigentlich mal ein Stream mit Serverless Computing?
Wieso machen wir doch ganz oft, ich lasse das Zeug einfach auf meinem Desktop laufen.
Es ist schwierig Linux-mäßig oder sonst was Serverless zu zeigen.
Was wir machen können ist, wir können mal irgendwelche Firebase oder irgendwie sowas verwenden.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie spannend das ist.
In der Virtualisierung spricht man eigentlich auch nicht von Containern.
Das habe ich auch so nicht gemeint.
Es gibt bei allen Guides stets halt drinnen, so nach dem Motto Container sind keine VMs.
Aber dann werden Container trotzdem wieder so beschrieben wie VMs.
Was ja eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt, weil ein Container ist kein eigenes System an sich.
Es ist ein stinknormaler weiterer Prozess auf deinem Hostsystem, wie jeder andere Prozess auch.
Nur, dass noch ein bisschen Sandbox-Kram drumherum ist oder dazwischen ist oder sonst was.
Deswegen kannst du ja auch in Container A nicht Kernel-Module verwenden.
Und in Container B quasi ein anderes Kernel-Modul, das geht nicht.
Das ist alles ein Prozess unter dem gleichen Host.
Okay, also wie legen wir jetzt den hier mal Containers an?
Was machen wir eigentlich die Ubuntu-Installation?
Die ist am installieren.
Create Container.
Okay, 123456.
123456.
Hostname.
Omega-Lul.
Next.
Template.
Ubuntu.
So, wir müssen mal Docker PXE.
Oh Gott.
Okay, Firefox, alles klar, Restarte.
Übrigens, der Firefox packt dann auch immer ganz gerne rum und startet sich nicht neu, obwohl er sagt Restarting.
Denn she baited so richtig.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich sollte mal meine VM neu starten.
Ach du.
Soll ich da noch alles nachinstallieren?
Okay, nee, startet die VM nicht neu.
Da hat sich sogar die Anmeldung gemerkt.
So, Docker Proxmox.
Hier, Proxmox mit Docker im LXT-Container.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Also mit der aktuellen Proxmox-Version lässt sich Docker auch in einem LXT-Container betreiben.
Was natürlich viel besser ist als in einer VM, weil man dann nicht sinnloserweise nochmal eine Virtualisierungssache dazwischen hat.
Die man gar nicht braucht.
Damit dies funktioniert sind aber, okay, der neue Container muss unprivileged sein.
Mittlerweile Standard.
Hier müssen Key, CTL und Nesting aktiviert sein.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt machen.
Sonst funktioniert das Ganze nämlich nicht.
Also, neue Container.
Doxor.
Passwort 123456, 123456.
Unprivileged haben wir hier drin.
Sehr gut, Template.
Es ist irgendwie wichtig, was man für ein Template nimmt.
Weil wir nicht nehmen wir irgendeinen Alpi...
Komm, wir nehmen mal das Plotted Template.
Da ist auf jeden Fall alles dabei.
Root Disk 8G.
Ja, wunderbar, reicht.
Ein Core Memory reicht auch.
Network, wunderbar.
Ach, Advanced.
Ich dachte, das muss man nachher mal installieren machen.
Confirm.
Wo stellt man den ganzen anderen Kram ein?
Das stellt man erst nach dem Anlegen an, oder?
Finish.
Da ist er.
Create.
Was macht der denn jetzt?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was er...
Ich glaube, da hat das ISO das Image extrahiert oder so was.
So, und jetzt gehen wir in die Settings und stellen was ein.
Options, Features.
Options.
Features.
Lasting und das da, okay.
Alles klar.
Docker lässt sich jetzt problemlos in einem LXC-Container installieren und ausführen.
Okay, wenn das alles ist, ist das ja...
Ehrlich gesagt...
Aber gucken wir mal, ob das...
ist.
Start.
Console.
Postchamp.
Ah.
Ist es root?
Okay, das heißt, die...
Die Container-Geschichte bei...
Proxmox ist also eher Richtung LXD, also quasi...
Nein.
Man macht nicht wie bei Docker einen einzelnen Prozess,
sondern man containerisiert sich quasi ein komplettes Betriebssystem-Image
mit Init und allem, was dazugehört.
Also sprich, man kann sich einloggen, hat eine Shell und so was.
Docker hat ja ein bisschen, oder Potman, oder...
Oder auch letztendlich...
Wenn du deine Sachen in Kubernetes laufen lässt,
da ist ja der Ansatz eher,
man startet nicht ein komplettes Init, was ein komplettes System startet,
sondern man startet nur das Programm, was man starten will.
TomDrix, zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Excellent-Subscription.
So, das heißt, ich hab jetzt hier ein ganz normales Ubuntu drin.
Okay.
Das ist schlecht.
Und wie krieg...
What the fuck, und wie komm ich jetzt da nach außen?
Max, altes Haus, wie geht's dir?
Joa, geht so.
Ich schließ mal daraus, du bist schon lange am Start, auch auf YouTube.
Doch klar, kannst du...
Inits-Sachen, oder ganz generell...
Gut, die haben, glaub ich, kein vollständiges Init hier laufen.
Die haben irgendwelche Startscripte, die andere Sachen...
Aber guck, es ist mehr oder weniger ein komplettes,
noch mal ein komplett eigenes Ubuntu, was hier läuft.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn du da ChangeRoute machst.
So, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Moment, Route? Nee, IPRO.
Wie krieg ich dem jetzt gesagt?
Ach, man muss ihm sagen, dass er sich das per DHCP ziehen soll.
Ach so, ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das ist Default.
Okay, Network.
Nö, ist so eigentlich. Edit. Ach.
Okay, das ist aber auch wirklich das Einzige, was ich kenne,
was standardmäßig Static hat und man dann leer lassen darf,
anstatt dass die faultmäßig DHCP ausgewählt ist.
Das ist ja, also, jetzt nicht gerade intuitiv.
Weil ich mein, entweder kannst du DHCP machen.
Wozu soll ich Static konfigurieren?
Da könntest du mich zumindest darauf hinweisen, Achtung, keine IP eingetragen.
Okay, aber gut, der Chat weiß wieder Bescheid.
Der Chat hat wieder Ahnung, ich nicht, so wie immer.
So, und jetzt starten wir das mal neu.
Und gucken, ob wir jetzt ins Internet raus dürfen.
Auf was für eine Distro basiert, braucht man Debbie an.
Ah, das sieht doch jetzt schon viel besser aus.
Guck mal, jetzt funktioniert das schon mal gleich viel besser.
So, also das ist quasi eher so eine LXD-Virtualisierungsgeschichte,
Kontainerisierungsgeschichte, weniger eine Docker-Geschichte.
Aber das ist eigentlich echt ganz gut.
Und jetzt kann ich hier drinnen Docker-Gedöns laufen lassen.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir.
Ja, weil ich, das letzte Mal war das auch noch so.
Das letzte Mal musste man eine VM anlegen, um darin Docker-Gedöns laufen lassen zu können.
Das ist aber auch schon ein bisschen her, wo ich das ausprobiert habe.
Und das war auch der Grund, warum ich gesagt habe, nee, also es gefällt mir nicht so.
Weil wie gesagt, aktuell habe ich eine Kiste hier stehen, Ubuntu-Server drauf geklatscht.
Mit dem Debbie an 10 könnte ich auch leben, ja.
Und habe da einen Docker-Compose-File und 6, 7 Dinger laufen und fertig.
Läuft es denn nicht stabil? Weiß nicht.
Also so viele Leute wie Proxmox verwenden, würde ich schon sagen, dass das prinzipiell ganz gut läuft.
Debbie, ein größer Ubuntu. Nee, ich bin, ich mag Ubuntu-Server.
Was mir, das einzige, was mir richtig auf den Sack geht bei Ubuntu-Server ist das hier.
Vielleicht hat ja schon von euch einer mal die Ehre, das verwenden zu dürfen.
Irgendjemand bei den Ubuntu-Leuten kam auf die klorische Idee.
Es ist eine gute Idee, dass man seine Netzwerk-Config jetzt in Yammeln machen muss.
Richtig hängen geblieben, äh.
Also das finde ich total, also das finde ich mega hängen geblieben.
Netzwerk-Config in Yammeln zu machen, das finde ich echt richtig hängen geblieben.
Äh, ansonsten mag ich Ubuntu lieber.
Letztendlich muss man aber auch mehr ehrlicherweise sagen, Ubuntu ist ja so ein halbes Debian.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinns-Unterschied.
Aber keiner mag Netplan, das ist ja gerade das witzige daran.
So und hier drauf können wir uns jetzt einen Dogger installieren oder wie ist das?
Also okay, wir gucken erstmal, ob man sich da mal per SSH einloggen kann, ob das funktioniert.
Wir haben 2136, probieren wir mal.
SSH, 136, muss man das auch als Root machen?
Nein, das muss man nicht als Root machen.
Nee, Root ist wahrscheinlich einfach per SSH deaktiviert.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich der SSH-Config, weil es ist standardmäßig so, dass man sich per SSH eigentlich nicht per Root einloggen soll.
Und deswegen haben die wahrscheinlich, okay.
Erstmal den Vim installieren, die wichtigsten Sachen.
Okay, die wichtigsten Sachen sind Vim, Hardtop, T-Max.
Die drei Sachen braucht man immer, da kommt man nicht dran vorbei.
Was ich dann immer noch gerne installiere ist D-Stat für IO-Auslastung.
What the hell?
Nee, geht doch.
Aber Hardtop ist, also T-Max und die zwei Dinger braucht man immer.
Ohne kommst du auf Linux-Systeme quasi gar, also könnt ich nicht mehr leben.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal die SSH-Config editieren und gucken, ob Rootloggen vielleicht verboten ist.
Hier, Permit Rootloggen, yes.
Und jetzt darf ich da wahrscheinlich auch per Root drauf.
Wunderbar.
Also, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist für mich jetzt so ein echt richtiger Pluspunkt, den sich Porgsbox verdient hat.
So, dass ich das fast einsetzen könnte.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich nicht einsetzen, weil ich meine Kiste hier mit meinem Ubuntu-Server drauf schon fix und fertig habe und da eigentlich alles funktioniert.
Dass man jetzt keine VM mehr braucht, um Docker oder Podman oder sonst was verwenden zu können.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
So, das heißt, wir wollen abinstallen.
Gucken wir mal.
Das ist ein aktuelles Ubuntu, das sollte relativ gut passen.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das alles funktioniert mit Containern.
Containsorn.
Übrigens, was ein richtig cooles Dashboard ist, was ich euch bei Gelegenheit auch mal zeigen muss.
Gerade für Leute, die lieber ein kleines Webinterface haben, als da irgendwie Kommandozeilen mäßig großartig was zu machen, ist das hier.
Da kann man die Basics auch auf dem Linux-System recht gut über ein Webinterface erledigen mit.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das hier gibt.
Wie gesagt, ihr wisst ja, ich bin Kommandozeilenfan.
Ich bin ja Kommandozeilenfan.
Mich freut das, wenn ich das alles machen kann übers Terminal.
So, Docker PS.
Aha, hängt.
Nee, geht.
Ja wunderbar, ok.
Dann machen wir hier mal zu.
So, jetzt machen wir den Hallo-Welt-Container.
Testen wir jetzt mal, ob der funktioniert.
Und danach testen wir, ob der Who-Am-I-Container funktioniert, weil der braucht Netzwerkverbindung.
Hello, from Docker, ok.
Der Hello-Welt-Container funktioniert.
Der nächste Test funktioniert der Who-Am-I-Container.
Der Who-Am-I-Container ist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger ein Hello-Welt-Container, nur, dass man es über einen Browser abrufen kann.
So, kann ich den Kram runterladen?
Wunderbar.
Was, das Debian immer noch die Packages von Ubuntu-Servern?
Machen sie?
Nee, machen sie nicht, oder?
Warum sollten sie das machen?
Werden wir jetzt neu?
So, gucken wir mal, welcher Port ist dran?
Port 32768.
Also 12218, 2.136 war es, glaube ich.
Zack, funktioniert.
Ja, das ist nice.
So, Abinstall Docker Compose.
Das finde ich echt nice.
Äh, das ist ja auch ein Ubuntu.
Das ist, das ist ein Ubuntu im Proxmox, also Proxmox selbst auf Debian-Basis.
Echt?
Als ich abbenutzt habe auf dem anderen war, war das Ubuntu?
Ok.
Äh, welche Passwortverwaltung nutzt ihr auf der Arbeit?
Wir suchen gerade nach einer sinnvollen Lösung für kleine mittlere Teams.
Ähm, also wir hatten die ganze Zeit immer Key Pass, das weiß ich daheim auch hab.
Aber, irgendwelche Big Brain Stonks Leute haben sich jetzt überlegt, dass Key Pass zu schlecht ist.
Und deswegen müssten wir jetzt das hier verwenden.
Passt mal auf.
Äh, das empfehle ich, empfehle ich nicht.
Das will ich einfach noch sagen.
Jetzt müssen wir das hier verwenden.
Und das ist die schlimmste und hässlichste Windows Only Anwendung, die ich je gesehen habe.
Guckt euch das mal an, äh.
Ja.
Ich mein.
Ist das euer Ernst?
Passwort safe?
Alter.
Was soll das sein?
Ja, das müssen wir jetzt verwenden.
Und das Geile ist ja, das Geile ist ja, dass wir ähm, dass wir letztens so einen Verschlüsselungstrojaner am Start hatten.
Und das hat instant dazu geführt, dass der Passwort safe nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Weil das das falsche System verschlüsselt hat.
Aber Key Pass hat funktioniert.
Und dann haben sich die Leute gefragt, Max, hast du das Root Passwort noch irgendwo?
Da hab ich dann gesagt, nein, natürlich hab ich das Root Passwort nirgendswo mehr.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn ich das Root Passwort irgendwie noch bei mir gespeichert hätte?
Ja, aber ihr habt doch früher Key Pass gehabt.
Ist dann nicht das Root Passwort noch irgendwo drinne?
Da bin ich erstmal zu meinem Chef abgesagt.
Und hab ihn gefragt, ähm, darf ich denn das Root Passwort noch wissen?
Da meint er, ja, also jetzt schon.
Normalerweise nicht, aber jetzt dürfte ich das Root Passwort noch wissen.
Ja, und dann wusste ich das Root Passwort auch noch.
Weil ich das noch im Key Pass stehen hatte, der natürlich noch funktioniert hat.
Nachdem der Passwort safe war, nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Das ist eh geil.
Vielleicht kennen das manche auch so aus Super Business, Enterprise, Stonks, Läden, Firmen.
Die sind da immer super pingelig bei allem.
Aber wenn es mal nicht geht und auch so nicht geht, also so weit nicht geht, dass es auch wirklich Geld verloren geht,
dann wird auf einmal auf alle Stonks Sachen geschissen.
Oder dann wird auf einmal auf alles geschissen, was sonst ultra wichtig ist.
Und dann frage ich mich dann immer so, okay, ich sehe ein, dass gewisse Vorgaben und Abläufe,
dass das bis zu einem gewissen Grad alles sinnvoll ist.
Ich glaube, da stellt auch keiner irgendwo in Frage.
Aber wenn man dann doch im Ernstfall quasi auf die halblegalen Dinge, die man vorher abschaffen wollte,
doch zurückgreifen muss, weil das eigene System, was man aus Bürokratie-Overhead geschafft hat,
im Ernstfall nicht handlungsfähig ist, dann frage ich mich doch,
warum kommen die Leute nicht auf die Idee, sich zu sagen, okay, vielleicht ist das,
was wir da aufgebaut haben, doch nicht so das Beste.
Weil wenn das richtig gut durchdacht wäre alles, dann würde man auch einen Plan haben für den Ernstfall
und nicht auf so halblegale Dinge, die eigentlich keiner mehr haben kann, zurückgreifen müssen.
Dann hätte man ein ordentliches Ausfallkonzept, was das hier auch abfackelt.
Oh, hat man aber nicht.
Also, habe ich den Docker Compose jetzt schon installiert?
Ja, habe ich, wunderbar.
Wir machen mal ein simples Docker Compose-File.
Who am I example?
Oh, mit Traffic auch noch.
Jetzt wollte das jetzt aber echt wissen.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich kein Traffic mehr davor, davor Reverse Load Balance.
Okay, das können wir aber mal machen, weil dann sehen wir wenigstens, ob alles richtig funktioniert.
Machen wir jetzt mal.
Muss man das als Route laufen lassen? Eher nicht, aber ich habe keinen anderen User.
Komm, wir lassen das jetzt mal als Route laufen.
So, Nummer zur Erklärung, wer das nicht so oft verwendet.
Es gibt, wie gesagt, also Docker, denke ich, ist den meisten mittlerweile im Begriff.
Docker sind keine Container.
Das kann man nicht oft genug betonen.
Also, Docker ist nicht gleich Container.
Docker ist quasi ein GUI oder ein Frontend für die Verwaltung von Containern.
Docker ist nicht gleich Container, weil, egal was es ist, ob es Docker ist,
Potman ist, Kubernetes ist, Rancher OS ist, Atomic gab es früher noch, Core OS.
Ach, was es da nicht alles für Container-Managementgeschichten gibt.
Fällt euch noch was ein?
Gib noch zig andere Dinger.
OpenStack war doch immer alles.
So, und egal was man davon verwendet, unter der Haube ist das alles das Gleiche.
Das benutzt alles die gleichen Sachen, die im Linux Kernel drin sind.
Und sprich, ist es egal, ob ich Docker, Potman oder Kubernetes verwende,
unter der Haube verwende ich LXC-Container.
Also LXC nennt sich das Ding, was im Linux Kernel drin ist.
Es ist ein bisschen doppeldeutig, weil LXC auch eine minimale Frontend-Implementierung ist.
Und Ubuntu kam dann irgendwann an und hat aus LXC, LXD gemacht,
um das Ganze noch ein bisschen verwirrender zu machen.
Aber die ganzen Linux Kernel-Geschichten, das ist alles für alle Frontends das Gleiche.
Es gibt eine Implementierung im Linux Kernel, die sich zusammensetzt aus Cgroups und Namespaces.
Das ist so die Hauptsache.
Also Cgroups ist quasi sowas wie, ich kann Ressourcen-Management machen.
Das Prozess XY darf nicht mehr verwenden als 200 RAM und einen CPU-Kern und sowas.
Das ist Cgroups.
Und was Docker Compose ist, da komme ich jetzt gleich drauf, nachdem ich erklärt habe,
was das ganze Containergedöns eigentlich ist, nochmal im schnellen Verfahren.
So, das ist einmal Cgroups.
Das ist für so Ressourcen-Management zuständig.
Und dann gibt es Namespaces.
Das ist dafür da, dass man quasi dem Container vorgaukeln kann, dass Sachen anders sind.
Zum Beispiel, dass ein Container Verzeichnisse sieht, die es auf dem Host gar nicht gibt.
Oder dass man Netzwerksachen anlegen kann und der Container denkt,
das wäre das einzige Netzwerk, was es gibt und sowas in der Richtung.
Also die zwei Sachen. Es gibt Cgroups und Namespaces.
Das ist das, woraus sich Container zusammensetzen.
Und ein Liebungscontainer ist nichts anderes, wie ein stinknormaler Prozess mit Cgroups und Namespaces dazu.
Dementsprechend braucht es eigentlich keine zusätzlichen Ressourcen.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Prozess im Liebungscontainer, wie alles andere auch.
Und diese Sachen, egal ob es Docker, Potman, Kubernetes sind, das ist das, was man verwendet.
Wenn man jetzt C, C++, man kann das bestimmt mit C Sharp und Go mittlerweile auch machen,
man könnte sich, ich sag jetzt mal in Anführungsstrichen, ohne Probleme über die Kernel-APs
einen eigenen Container starten. Das ist kein Ding, das kann man machen.
Wenn man kann.
Aber nachdem nicht jeder Programmierer ist und sich mit Linux Kernel-Schnittstellen auskennt,
hat sich das Ganze so richtig erst durchgesetzt, als Docker dahergekommen ist
und dann einfach zu verwenden, das Frontend gebastelt hat für diese ganze Container-Geschichte.
Also, es ist kein Container, Docker ist ein Frontend dafür.
Natürlich macht Docker auch noch ein bisschen mehr, das hat, glaube ich, der Celmore im Chat ja auch noch gesagt.
Natürlich macht Docker noch ein bisschen mehr.
Neben dem, dass das Container erstellen kann.
Das gibt noch eine Registry, wo du Images runterladen kannst.
Die haben hier Docker-File-Format, wie man Images anlegt, wie man Snapshots macht.
Das ist ein bisschen mehr drumherum gebastelt.
Aber im Kern ist Docker ein Frontend für diese Cgroups-Namespaces-Geschichte im Kernel.
Genau, Overlay, FS4-File-System, das macht im Detail noch viel, viel mehr.
Aber unter der Haube ist das keine Magic im Endeffekt.
Und alle Container-Frontends, das worauf ich raus will, alle Container-Frontends,
ob Kubernetes, Potman, Docker, Rancher, Co., die verwenden alle unter der Haube die gleichen Geschichten im Kernel.
So und irgendwann ist man auf die Idee gekommen, dass Docker an sich ja eine coole Sache ist.
Aber es wäre praktisch, wenn man die Systeme, wenn man mehrere Systeme reproduzierbar aufbauen könnte.
Oder neu erstellen könnte.
Und dann da kommt Docker Compose ins Spiel.
Es gibt viele Überschneidungen.
Also sprich, das was Kubernetes macht, ist ja im Prinzip die neben dem was Docker macht mit Container anlegen.
Kubernetes ist hauptsächlich dazu da, einen gewissen definierten Zustand zu halten.
Also sprich, man sagt zum Beispiel, dieser Service muss auf drei verschiedene Hosts laufen oder
keine Ahnung, wenn auf dem Load Balancer so und so viel Last ist, dann mehr Container starten oder irgendwelche Geschichten.
Also Kubernetes ist dafür da, diese ganze Container-Geschichte, so wie man so schön sagt, zu orchestrieren.
Weniger jetzt als reines Container starten, stoppen, anlegen, Frontend.
Und nachdem Kubernetes ein ganz schön fettes Ding ist und es eigentlich total overkill ist,
da im privaten Bereich auf einem Rechner was zu machen, gibt es da ein bisschen leicht gewichtige Varianten.
Und das einfachste, was man machen kann, um seine Container reproduzierbar aufzubauen und zu versionieren, ist Docker Compose.
Also sprich, anstatt dass man jeden Docker Container von Hand startet und stoppt und Parameter angibt,
was man für Ordner verwenden will, was man für Ports verwenden will, schreibt man das alles in Jaml-File.
Und dann sagt man Docker Compose ab und der applied quasi alles, was in diesem Jaml-File drin steht.
Das einfachste Docker Compose-File sieht zum Beispiel so aus.
Obwohl, wir machen das jetzt mal hier mit.
So, docker-compose.yaml, set-paste, zack.
Was das jetzt macht ist, also wir kommen jetzt mal an, was das macht und was ich dafür von Hand machen müsste.
Das erstellt zwei Container und zwar einmal einen Container mit dem Namen traffic und einmal einen Container mit dem Namen whoami.
So, und was ist da drin?
Hier startet das Image, dieses Image, das muss halt irgendwo bereitgestellt werden.
Und hier startet dieses Image.
In dem Fall ist es so, das hier ist quasi ein Reverse-Proxy, HTTP, Load Palenser, Verschnitt und das hier ist der eigentliche Service.
Das könnte ich alles von Hand starten, aber so ist es einfacher.
Zumal der Vorteil davon ist, das Docker Compose-File kann ich ins Git einchecken, irgendwo pushen und auf einer anderen Kiste auschecken.
Und dann gehe ich einfach da rein, docker-compose, ab.
So, minus D, aber wir gucken jetzt zu.
Und dann legt der alles so an, wie es in diesem Compose-File...
Wo ordnet sich Swarm ein? Dazwischen.
Ich habe Swarm aber nie verwendet.
Ruhig dazu sein. Dazwischen.
Swarm hat wohl noch ein bisschen mehr Cluster-Management dabei.
Ich meine, Docker Compose ist ja auch komplett...
...lokal.
Weiß ich weiß.
Weiß ich, ob man damit auch irgendwas Remod machen kann, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Swarm ist noch ein bisschen Cluster-Management dabei, aber Swarm ist tot mittlerweile.
Also das wird wohl nicht mehr weiterentwickelt und alles hat sich auf Kubernetes eingeschossen.
So, guck, das war es jetzt.
Also sprich, was der jetzt gemacht hat, ist, der hat jetzt diese zwei Container gestartet.
Und jetzt kann ich auf diesen Server draufgehen.
IP wissen wir noch, 10.2.1.3.6.
Zack, und page not found, weil ich die falsche Domain angegeben habe.
Okay, das war mein Fail.
Das funktioniert ohne DNS natürlich nicht richtig.
Weil ich habe ihm gesagt, ich will Domain verwenden.
Whoami.localhost.
Und Whoami.localhost...
Naja, Whoami.localhost geht halt von hier aus nicht.
So, was wir aber machen können, ist, wir machen jetzt Matrix 17.
Abinstall Firefox.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Da muss ich nämlich nichts umstellen.
Wir starten jetzt Remod mal an Firefox auf der Kiste.
PauseChamp.
Das ist auch immer was, wo viele Leute erst mal gucken und denken, was das funktioniert.
Ja, Kubernetes Setup ist absolut cancer, ey.
Was ich bei Kubernetes auch fragwürdig finde,
also was ich auch bei vielen anderen Projekten auch fragwürdig finde, ist,
wenn die anfangen, schon bekannte Sachen umzubenennen.
So nach dem Motto, das sind jetzt Pots und sowas.
Muss das sein?
Kann man nicht die Dinge einfach so nennen, wie sich die restliche Welt da was drunter vorstellt?
Da gibt es noch mehr Projekte, die sowas gerne machen.
Ich hab letztens, was war denn das? Ich hab letztens in Webcast gesehen.
Was war das denn?
Ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen.
Da haben sie auch alles unbenannt.
Ja, Pots sind in, der Kellner hat natürlich recht,
Pots ist in Kubernetes so die kleinste Einheit, die du managen kannst.
Du kannst ja, glaube ich, gar keine Container direkt managen.
Aber ich mag das nicht, wenn manche Projekte anfangen,
altbekannte Sachen dann neue Namen zu geben, dass es fresher klingt irgendwie.
So. Ach so.
Ich bin ja auch blöd.
So.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich hab jetzt in Firefox gestartet.
Ich hab jetzt in Firefox gestartet, der auf der Remote-Kiste läuft.
Das ist richtig Trick 17. Das kann man sich auch mal merken.
Also Notizblock zücken.
Wie hättest du denn einen Pot genannt? Keine Ahnung.
Zum Glück muss ich, ihr wisst, wie schlecht ich bin mit Namen, was Variable angeht.
Vielleicht Unit oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Pot war jetzt auch ein schlechtes Beispiel.
Container Group vielleicht oder sowas.
Irgendetwas, wo man sich ein bisschen was drunter vorstellen kann.
Weil Container Group trifft es ja auch nicht so richtig.
So. Also.
Compose ab.
Jetzt haben wir in Firefox auf.
So. Und wenn man nämlich...
Wenn man sich nämlich per SSH verbindet auf einen Server und sagt SSH minus Y,
dann kann man grafische Anwendungen auf dem Server über SSH lokal anzeigen lassen.
Geht nur, wenn man einen X-Server laufen hat.
So. Und jetzt kann ich mal an whoami.localhost und siehe da.
Das geht nicht.
What?
Das liegt...
Hey.
Okay, keine Ahnung, warum das nicht geht.
Ich hätte eigentlich erwartet, dass das tut.
Vielleicht ist es auch der Firefox.
Moment, vielleicht ist es auch einfach der Firefox, der komische Dinge macht.
Wir machen mal einen Curl.
Whoami.localhost.
Ich hätte jetzt erwartet, dass das Beispiel einfach funktioniert von denen.
Gestartet ist es auch.
Ach so, Moment, ich muss das Host-File wahrscheinlich anpassen.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Ich kann ja gar nicht whoami.localhost machen, weil es die Domain nicht...
Moment, kein Curl installiert.
Lul.
Man müsste die Host-Satei eintragen.
Ja, das müsste funktionieren.
Okay.
PC.
Host.
Whoami.
So, da sind wir.
Jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Guckt, Firefox.
Whoami.localhost.
Zack, da ist es.
Ja, in dem Fall ist Traffic natürlich komplett bescheuert, aber das war im Beispiel halt einfach so drinnen.
Für so eine einfache Sache braucht man das nicht.
So, und jetzt ist der Vorteil davon, dass ich diese Datei nehmen könnte, einfach auf eine andere Kiste kopieren.
Starten, es wird funktionieren.
Und warum das für mich jetzt im Privat, also für mich jetzt besonders praktisch ist,
ich würde da jetzt einen Git-Repo draus machen und würde dann quasi Comets machen mit den Änderungen.
Das heißt, ich kann auch nachgucken, wie habe ich mal was gemacht und vor allem,
warum habe ich da mal irgendwie was dran geändert.
So, und so sieht das aktuell auf meiner Server, auf meinem Mini 2HE-Kiste,
die hier neben mir steht, auch so aus.
Ich habe da einfach 7 Services drin definiert und eingestellt, dass Traffic dafür,
das haben wir übrigens mal im Stream gemacht, Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate ausstellt.
Deswegen haben alle meine lokalen Services halt gültige Zertifikate.
Und es ist ganz nützlich, weil man alle Sachen mit Docker Compose direkt managen kann.
Also man kann zum Beispiel sagen, okay, einfach alle Sachen, die da drin stehen, stoppen und starten.
Ja, jeder stimmt.
Also wenn man das jetzt rüberkopiert auf einen anderen Server und startet,
dann hat man die Daten, die man hier drauf hat, natürlich nicht mitkopiert.
Man würde dort da neue Container erzeugen.
Was hast du denn im Docker?
Oh, da muss ich immer in mich gehen.
Was habe ich?
Ich habe einen Doku-Wiki, ich habe einen Git-Dings hier, Frontend.
Warte mal, ich habe einen Doku-Wiki, einen Git-Frontend.
Ich habe einen Samba-Server.
Ich habe eine Traffic für Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate.
Ich habe einen Container, der die anderen updatet.
Ich habe noch einen Nextcloud, den ich aber weg haben will.
Ich habe so einen Fritzbox-Cardav-Kontakte zu Fritzbox- und Fritzphone-Converter.
Jetzt habe ich ja noch alles drauf laufen.
Fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein.
Zwei, drei Sachen sind es noch.
Es ist jetzt nicht so viel.
Ich kann jetzt leider nicht reingucken, weil da stehen auch sicher ein paar Sachen drin,
die ich nicht leaken will.
Wie war das mit dem SSH und GUI?
Kannst du das nochmal kurz zeigen?
Ja klar, kann ich machen.
Also, wenn du dich auf eine Kiste verbindest per SSH, das da hinten, lassen wir jetzt mal
weg.
Da musst du einfach, die alte Variante war minus X, mittlerweile ist es minus Y.
Hast du einen lokalen Git-Server?
Du machst SSH minus Y.
Das sorgt dafür, dass wenn du dich einloggst, also der teilt an dem SSH-Server mit, dass
du X-Forwarding machen willst.
Das ist der Parameter für X-Forwarding.
Dann sagst du dem Server, hallo, ich möchte X-Forwarding machen.
Das setzt natürlich voraus.
Doch, minus X geht noch, aber es war irgendein Unterschied zwischen minus X und minus Y.
Wir können mal kurz gucken, was der Unterschied ist.
Okay, also der Unterschied ist, Enable 6-Forwarding.
So, und was ist minus Y?
Okay, das ist der Unterschied, frag mich nicht.
Da muss man wahrscheinlich irgendwelche anderen Sachen, früher hat man immer minus X verwenden,
ich habe eigentlich nur minus Y.
Max spiegelt sich in der SSD ja schon die ganze Zeit, scheiße.
Jetzt sehe ich es ja jetzt erst.
Ich spiegel mich in der SSD.
Doch, minus X geht noch.
Also, du machst minus Y, damit teilst du dem SSH-Server mit, hallo, ich möchte X-Forwarding
machen, dann loggst du dich ganz normal ein und wenn du dich das erste Mal einloggst,
erstellt der sowas hier.
Ich kann das mal kurz löschen, dass du siehst, wie das ausschaut.
Wenn du dich dann das erste Mal einloggst, dann legt er so einen X-Authority-File an.
Das ist irgendwie dafür da, dass einer deine Session nicht hijacken kann, frag mich nicht,
ich weiß es im Detail nicht.
Wenn du das siehst, weißt du schon mal, aha, hat alles funktioniert und dann kannst du
einfach eine grafische Anwendung starten über SSH.
Man muss aber sagen, das ist langsam, wie du hier siehst, also Geschwindigkeitsrekorde
gewinnst du mit einer grafischen Anwendung über SSH nicht.
Ach ja, und der Phipps hat recht, das muss aktiviert sein.
Also, wenn der SSH-Server kein X-Forwarding erlaubt, geht das nicht, aber mir ist kein
Betriebssystem, was mir jetzt so einfällt, was standardmäßig X-Forwarding deaktiviert
hätte.
Vielleicht Co-OS oder sowas.
Du könntest in Samba vier Domain-Controller bestimmt als Docker-Container starten.
Jaja, garantiert.
Aber da weiß ich nicht wie, weil die Samba-Config ist ätzend.
Also, wir können jetzt mal hier WebGL-Test machen, da sehen wir mal, wie lahm das Ganze
ist.
Kommt mal, ihr seht schon, wie lahm die Seite, wie lahm die Seite lädt, ne?
Also, also schnell ist das wirklich nicht.
Wir können mal meinen Twitch-Stream anmachen.
Oha, hier.
SSH-X-Forwarding Firefox.
Sieht halt schon ein bisschen kaputt aus, ne?
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
H-P-N-S-S-H.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass es an das aktuelle RDP rankommen wird mit 3D-Beschleunigungsgedöns
und sowas.
Also, das ist halt der Witz, ne?
Ihr seht schon, guck mal, hier ein neuer Tab, wie es ruckelt.
Mal Twitch-Woblords aufmachen.
Ihr seht schon, was das für ein Input-Leck hat.
Arch hat es standardmäßig aus.
Ok, das wird mir sogar einleuchten, weil die haben ja standardmäßig auch noch nicht mal
ein SSH-Serverlauf, ne?
Also, sie mussten auch von Hand einschalten und sowas.
Die sagen halt, sie sind Desktop.
Gibt es jemanden, der Arch-Linux oder Gentoo auf dem Server verwendet von euch?
Mag ja so ein paar Hardcore-Leute geben, aber ich glaube, das ist verschwindend gering.
Stellt euch mal vor, müsst ihr irgendwie Libreenszenen erstmal ne Runde kompilieren,
ne?
Ja, also guckt mal hier, das ist wirklich...
Also, schnell ist was anderes, ne?
Schnell ist was anderes.
Ja, aber es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Zum Ausprobieren ist das gut.
Und wisst ihr, wofür ich das auf der Arbeit lange verwendet hab?
Remote SSH-Browser, wir hatten mal ne Kiste, da war, glaubst du, sogar ne Oracle-Linux-Vollinstallation drauf.
Das musste ne Oracle-Linux-Vollinstallation sein, weil das das einzige war, was irgendwo
vom Hersteller supportet war, frag mich nicht.
Und da lief ein Service drauf, das war irgendein Dokumenten-Management-System.
Und das hatte ne Admin-Interface.
Und dieses Admin, also natürlich, wir reden ja hier vom Business-Enterprise-Stonks-Umfeld,
da sind die Sachen nicht so einfach, wie man sich das immer so vorstellt.
Die Version, die haben wir mal gekauft und danach haben wir keine Updates mehr gekauft.
Das heißt, wir hatten ein Dokumenten-Management-System, was seit 5 Jahren nicht mehr supportet war
und was auch niemand wieder neu aufbauen konnte.
Und das Dokumenten-Management-System hatte halt ne Admin-Interface.
So, und das Admin-Interface, das wollte man halt dadurch, dass es eben so ein uralt unsupportetes
Sonstwas-Ding ist, nicht einfach ins Netzwerk stellen.
Deswegen haben wir gesagt, ok, Zugriff auf das Admin-Interface nur von Localhost und
haben es komplett überall gesperrt.
Und Zugriff auf das Admin-Interface haben wir dann gemacht per SSH, äh, per Browser
über SSH.
Es gibt noch andere Varianten, man könnte auch Portweiterleitung über SSH machen, aber
das war ne Weile.
Ich mein, besser als LYNX oder irgendwie so komisches Zeug verwenden.
Wenn so etwas abbraucht, ist man richtig am Sack, ja.
Wir haben aktuell auch was.
Das ist ein Seminarbuchungssystem.
Ja, sowas, sowas.
Also sprich, dort können sich Außendienstleute anmelden, um Seminare zu buchen.
Da kriegen sie dann erzählt hier die tollen neuen, was weiß ich, Versicherungsprodukte,
die ihr verkaufen könnt und sowas.
So, und dieses System haben wir gekauft.
Das ist so ne richtige Stonks-Story jetzt, wo wirklich wieder die absoluten Spezialisten
am Start fahren.
Also, man hat sich das gekauft damals, hat aber gesagt, bevor man es gekauft hat, dass
es eigentlich nicht so das System ist, was man haben will.
Was eigentlich schon wieder ein bisschen merkwürdig ist.
Warum kauft man es dann?
Wahrscheinlich gehört die Firma irgendwie in einem Neffe von einem oder so, weiß nicht.
So, und zumindest, man hat das System gekauft und hat quasi schon im gleichen Atemzug gesagt,
ah ja gut, aber so wirklich das, was wir brauchen, ist es nicht.
Aber dann hat die, der Hersteller hat natürlich Geld gewettert und hat gesagt, aha, kein
Problem, wir passen es euch an.
So, also, haben wir unser Seminarbuchungssystem gekauft, quasi mit einem Entwicklungsvertrag
mit dem Softwarehersteller, dass der das so umwurstet für uns, dass das uns gefällt.
So, und dann haben sie festgestellt, als das fertig war und es installiert war auf den
Surfer, haben sie festgestellt, oh scheiße, pass mal auf, das ist kein Witz, das Ding
basiert ja noch auf Cold Fusion.
Weißt du, ob das noch jemand kennt?
Das ist doch Cold Fusion.
So, und dann kam das nächste Problem, Cold Fusion ist ja komplett, ja, verwendet kein
mehr und, ja, das braucht irgendwie eine Java Runtime oder so, ne?
Das braucht, ne, das braucht einen JBoss, das braucht einen JBoss, das braucht einen
JBoss auf Java Basis, dass es läuft.
Ich versuch das gerade aus dem Kopf zu rekonstruieren und das Problem war dann, dass die, diese
Version, die die verwendet haben, nur mit einem alten JBoss lief, der allerdings so
alt war, dass die, das Red Hat, das Java, was im Repo war, zu neu gewesen ist.
So, so, genau, also sprich, wir konnten das Ding, obwohl es neu gekauft war, nicht so
ported auf unseren Systemen betreiben.
Also richtig, eine richtig absolute Big Brain Entscheidung war das Ganze.
So, und jetzt um die Brücke, um die Brücke zum Thema Container zu schlagen, ähm, der
Kellner hat's schon erraten, der hat's schon erraten, um jetzt die Brücke zu Container
zu schlagen, wir haben uns damit eins, zwei Jahre rumgequält, ähm, und haben gesagt,
hey, wir können das System nicht supporten, wir können das System noch nicht mal wieder
aufbauen.
Wenn das System Schrott ist, dann ist es Schrott, wir können das nicht wieder aufbauen.
So, und da sagen natürlich alle immer, ja, ja, kein Problem, das passt schon, außer wenn
dann die Kacke am dampfen ist, dann passt es auf einmal doch nicht mehr.
Und jetzt haben wir es so gemacht, wir haben das System einfach in einen Container gepackt,
also sprich, wir haben jetzt den gleichen Server wie vorher, gleicher Name, gleicher
Alles, nur dass dort drauf nochmal ein Docker läuft, wo jetzt diese Anwendung drin containerisiert
wird, voll durch die Brust ins Auge, ja.
Und manchmal gibt's Probleme, weil, äh, der Hersteller doch, also wir haben ja noch
einen Supportvertrag mit dem Hersteller, der Hersteller liefert ab und zu nochmal irgendwelche
Updates, und dann, dann geht der Restart manchmal nicht und so ganz merkwürdige Dinge, also,
das geile ist, Leute von euch, die wahrscheinlich so im Business, Stonks, Enterprise, Umfeld
arbeiten, die kennen das, solche Software gibt es, sammelt sich mit den Jahren immer
mehr an.
Und irgendwann hast du wirklich einen ganzen Zoo von so einem Geschiss, und keiner traut
sich mehr, jemals was abzuschalten, weil alle Schiss haben, irgendjemand der wichtig ist
und Kontakte zum Vorstand hat, braucht das System.
Da hast du dann Dinger, die kosten dich Zehntausende, wenn nicht Hunderttausende Euro, und es verwenden
noch zwei Leute für Sachen, die noch nicht mal wichtig sind.
Seine Q, das ist alles Erfahrungssache.
Das kommt mit der Zeit.
Ich bin gar nicht so big brain, wie es aussieht.
Vielleicht, wenn man das erste Mal hier vorbeiguckt.
Exposed.
Außerdem, ihr wisst ja, das wichtigste, was man braucht, um big brain zu werden, also
neben einem Sub auf Twitch, das ist natürlich das allerwichtigste, ist, man braucht ein
gutes Klo.
Ohne gutes Klo geht nichts.
Weil, wie viele Sachen einem alles auf dem Klo einfallen, wo man den ganzen Tag dran
sitzt, und dann sitzt man auf dem Klo und sagt, ah, so geht das also.
Also, Kloinvestition lohnt sich.
So, wir sind jetzt ein bisschen weit vom Thema abgekommen, wir waren eigentlich bei Proxbox.
Also, das mit Docker Zeug hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Wir haben unser Container laufen, wir haben Docker Compose ausprobiert, hat auch wunderbar
funktioniert.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal schauen, was macht eigentlich unsere Ubuntu VM, ist die mittlerweile
fertig installiert?
Wir müssen nämlich noch Pass-Through testen mit der VM.
Der Serious Max hat eine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Er sagt nämlich, bei mir in der Wohnung wird es irgendwie nicht richtig warm, ich habe
das Gefühl, dass die Heizung kaputt ist, kannst du mir ein Tool empfehlen, um meine Heizung
zu tracken?
Zufälligerweise habe ich da was gebaut, um die Heizung zu tracken, und zwar kann ich
euch das Ganze mal zeigen.
Nein, drauf scheiß drauf.
Irgendwann ist es auch mal ausgelutscht.
Irgendwann ist es auch mal gut.
So ein paar Mal pro Stream kann man den Gag ja machen, aber irgendwann ist es ja mal gut.
Verwendest du die Proxmo Kiste dann auch ein bisschen weiter?
Ich werde es mir wahrscheinlich morgen noch ein bisschen Offstream angucken, so die Feinheiten,
aber die Kiste da oben rechts, wo das drauf läuft, die da, also da drauf kannst du ja
nichts ernsthaft betreiben.
Ich meine, das ist ein Low-End-2-Core-Kack-Ding, da geht ja gar nichts drauf.
Moment, was habe ich gesagt, wollte ich jetzt noch machen?
Ob man PC-Karten durchreichen kann.
Genau.
So, was macht denn die Ubuntu-VM?
Die sagt, oh fuck, ich habe den Installer verpennt.
Jetzt muss die ja noch installieren.
Na gut, dann können wir jetzt die Netzwerk-Karte einbauen, würde ich sagen, in der Zwischenzeit.
Leute, sollen wir mutig sein und die PCI-Karte in das Board reinstecken, während es in Betrieb
ist, und gucken, was passiert?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
So, nächste Frage, Chet.
Nächste Frage, ähm, welchen PCI-Slot verwenden wir?
Den Adapter auf M2 oder den richtigen PCI-Slot?
Den da oder den da?
Ich bin für den hier, ich bin für den hier, weil dann sind die Chancen, wenn es irgendwie
abfackelt, größer, dass das Board überlebt.
Dann geht nur dein Adapter kaputt.
Okay, äh, wir installieren den Basic Ubuntu-Server mit OpenSSR, continue.
Okay, ähm, probieren wir mal aus.
Ich mach mal Fullscreen, dass ihr der ganzen Sache beiwohnen könnt, wenn es jetzt abkackt.
Warum sollte nur der Adapter kaputt gehen?
Naja, wenn man es über den Adapter macht, sind zumindest die Chancen da, dass nur der
Adapter kaputt geht.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn es kaputt geht, geht wahrscheinlich alles kaputt.
So, probieren wir mal aus.
Ja, exzellent.
Ja, 10G-Karte.
Ich hab das Slotblast schon abgemacht, weil sonst würd's da nicht drauf passen.
Ohje.
Habe...
Oh, Leute.
Geht nicht.
Seht ihr, das passt nicht.
Doch, hier unten reinmachen.
Passt nicht.
Ah, ja.
Eifischend ist das am besten an.
Läuft's noch?
Okay.
Äh...
Ich glaub, es ist abgekackt.
Oh, es ist abgekackt.
Leute, die Kiste läuft nicht mehr.
Grip.
Hot Swap failed.
Aber ist kein Problem.
Wir schalten aus und schalten wieder ein.
Ist alles kein Ding.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es funktioniert.
Ich mach mal kurz die...
He doesn't know.
He lacks critical information.
Aber guckt mal.
Da blinkt's noch.
Seht ihr?
Der Cursor blinkt noch.
Also das System ist nicht abgekackt.
Kann das sein, dass der durcheinander gekommen ist,
weil das eine zweite Netzwerkkarte ist?
Dass der jetzt nicht weiß, welche Netzwerkkarte er anmachen soll?
Okay.
Ich mach mal aus und wieder an.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Schauen wir mal.
Check mal die IP.
Ja, da muss ich die Tastatur umstecken.
Das klappt nicht so einfach.
Aber mal gucken, ob er startet.
Ultra Durable.
Okay, kaputt ist er schon mal, nicht?
Gut, er meckert jetzt ein bisschen rum,
weil ich im laufenden Betrieb ausgeschaltet hab.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Das darf er machen.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal, ob der jetzt wieder da ist.
Da ist er wieder.
Okay, das scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Er pinkt auch wieder.
Das da oben können wir zumachen.
Das wird nicht mal gehen.
Mal gucken, ob er das jetzt erkannt hat, die Netzwerkkarte.
Port 1, nee.
Ja, guck mal.
Zwei Netzwerkkarte erkannt.
Nee, Moment.
Doch.
Zwei Netzwerkkarte erkannt.
Sehr gut.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob das Durchreichen in die VM funktioniert.
Oh, nee.
Ich hätte die Ubuntu Installation durchlaufen lassen sollen.
Weil jetzt ist ja die Installation mittendrin abgekackt.
Booting vom Hard Drive.
RIP.
Aber die Installation dauert nicht lang.
Das dauert 10 Minuten oder so, wenn es hochkommt.
Wenn man dann dabei bleibt.
Wie sagt man denn, das ist...
Okay, da können wir das nächste Problem uns hier gleich...
Alter, geh mal fort mit der Konsole.
Da können wir uns das nächste Problem gleich angucken.
Shutdown.
Wie macht man Boot-Reihenfolge?
Hier, Boot-Order.
Network.
Ja.
Warum ist Pepe Love im Stream-Chat-Fanze?
Keine Ahnung.
Äh.
Was will der von mir?
Ich will ausschalten.
Stop.
Hallo, ich will die VM ausschalten.
Warum kann ich die VM nicht ausschalten?
Stop.
Äh.
Wie kriege ich denn eine VM ausgeschaltet?
Irgendwie forsten, ja.
Okay, aber das muss doch übers Web-Interface gehen, ausschalten.
Was auf Monitor links klicken und dann alles quitt?
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Da gibt es kein...
Can't log file.
Jetzt ist aus.
Warum gibt es da keinen Button, was das macht?
Also, ich erwarte mal zumindest, dass man Force ausmachen kann.
Klar, dass der normale Shutdown nicht funktioniert, ist klar.
Ich kann nichts installieren, da ist kein System drauf.
So, hat er jetzt die Boot-Reihenfolge umgestellt?
Boot Order Network.
Gut.
Jetzt können wir Start machen wieder.
Console.
Abgestürzt, Damage set up.
Aber das war nicht abgestürzt, das hing im Boot.
Und ist Boot gleich, er ist abgestürzt, sorry.
Das kann so ziemlich jeder anderen Virtualisierungslösung.
Du hast halt so einen Force-Stop-Knopf.
Hast du ja hier auch, ne?
Kann ich auch sagen, hier, Power off.
Das ist ja quasi Force-Stop.
So, auf.
So, Linux Network installs.
Eine Runde.
What?
Hallo?
Linux Network installs.
Unto, jawoll, install.
Power off ist beim Vmware-Stack heraus.
Ja, aber genau so was will ich ja.
Wenn er hängt, Power off, bam.
Hast du eine Software-Verteilung?
Ne, ich habe nur einen PXE-Server.
Ich habe den hier.
Netboot.
Den da.
Dazu musst du im Prinzip einfach nur diesen Container starten.
Und in deinem DHCP den Server als Boot-Server angeben.
Das war's.
Also, du startest einfach nur den Container.
Und die IP von dem Container-Host gibst du in deinem DHCP als Next-Server an.
Das war's.
Mehr musst du nicht machen.
Das ist wirklich easy.
Ja, wie gesagt, über Konsole habe ich jetzt ja gerade erfahren, dass es funktioniert.
Aber ich finde es merkwürdig, dass es da keine Knopföl gibt.
So, jetzt machen wir das Ganze mal hier im Schnelldurchgang.
Face-Reveal, wenn ich mich das nächste Mal in der SSD spiegele.
Ja, Test-VM.
Wir sind in Turks and Kaikos Island.
Oder sind wir in Trinidad and Tobago?
Ich kann mich nicht ganz entscheiden.
Hier, Turkmenistan, alles klar.
Oh nee, jetzt habe ich den Mirror aus Turkmenistan.
Ich glaube, das ist keine so gute Idee.
Ich glaube, den Mirror aus Turkmenistan will ich nicht.
Nee, nee, wir sind zu null.
Zu null könnten wir sein.
Nee, wir nehmen irgendwas, wo der Mirror schnell ist.
Germany, komm, gut.
Der ist schnell, vertraut mir.
Ganz bestimmt ist der schnell.
Wieso, oder läuft er bei dir auf dem Raspberry Pi irgendwo am DSL?
109395074286 exquisite Name.
Fracht im Chat, benutzt du in deiner Linux-VM auch die Multi-Monitor-Funktion?
Nein, verwende ich nicht.
Ich habe zwei Rechner mit zwei Monitoren.
Ich habe die Monitore zwar unterschiedlich verbunden mit den Rechnern.
Ich könnte theoretisch jeden Monitor von jedem Rechner verwenden.
Aber ich mache es meistens unter linkem Monitor.
Das ist an dem einen Rechner, der rechte Monitor ist an dem anderen Rechner.
Ich verwende eigentlich so gut wie nie Dual-Head oder wie das heißt.
Und VM auch gar nicht.
Kann ich dir nichts zu sagen.
Auf der Arbeit ist es so, da haben wir so einen 4K-Curved-Widescreen.
Und wenn ich da eine VM in Fullscreen habe, geht es halt auch, weil es sind halt keine zwei unterschiedlichen Monitore.
Hast du dann zwei Mäuse? Ich habe sogar drei Mäuse hier gerade nebeneinander stehen.
Aber nee, ich kann mit der Maus von hier rüber auf den anderen Bildschirm fahren.
Das mache ich hiermit.
Ja, Maus Without Borders nennt sich das.
Warum kein KVM?
Na, weil es viel besser ist, wenn ich hier rüber kann mit der Maus, als dass ich das rumschalten muss.
Barrier, das war früher Synergy. Heute gibt es Barrier.
Use Entire Disk, ja.
Das haben die umbenannt. Das kann man auch gut verwenden.
Aber nachdem ich ja nur von Windows auf Windows gehe, nehme ich halt ne Windows-Ondi-Software, die funktioniert.
Synergy funktioniert auch, aber ist ein bisschen komplizierter einzurechnen.
Alter, die Musik.
So, auf Ubuntu mach hinne.
Ja, auf.
Chat, um den Chat zu erfreuen.
Den Chat zu erfreuen.
Ups.
Um den Chat zu erfreuen. Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Geh fort.
So, jetzt genug jetzt.
Jetzt hab ich mein Headset verstellt, weil mir zwischen Rinalt Brunner gefallen ist.
Excellent.
Das war noch ein iPhone 6, ja.
Die Kamera ist ein iPhone XS.
Die Kamera liegt auf dem Arm, exakt.
Zum Glück hat man nicht den anderen Arm gesehen, der ist nämlich total verkratzt, weil sich die Katze halt wieder ausgetobt hat.
Press F. Nee, ich leb noch.
Das neue iPhone SE ist ja so ungefähr die Größe oder ist glaube ich exakt die Größe.
Die verwenden wahrscheinlich das olle Zeug dafür.
Das alte iPhone SE ist mir ein bisschen klein.
Ich hab ja meiner Mutter ein iPhone SE gekauft, ein altes.
Und da haben wir jetzt die Schriftgröße ganz fett gestellt, dass man nur ob was trifft.
Gut, die ist jetzt 70, vielleicht liegt es auch daran, dass sie das nicht mehr so gut mit dem Finger trifft.
Aber das wär mir auch ein bisschen klein.
Die ist wirklich Boomer, was das angeht.
Nee, ich bin eher Doomer, weil ich bin Jahr 2000 so am Start gewesen.
Ich bin 1984 geboren, das heißt ich war 2016.
Aber das war 2000, war das ehwitzig.
Du hattest ja welche, die haben wirklich geglaubt, dass die Welt morgen nicht mehr existiert so nach dem Motto.
Ich hab auch gedacht, es wird morgen exakt so sein wie vorher, bloß wird kein Silvester mehr sein.
Und es ist ja auch nichts passiert.
Es ist nichts nennenswertes passiert im Jahr 2000.
Die haben das gehypt fast das ganze Jahr lang über.
Aber es ist nichts passiert.
Paar Jahre später gab es dann Mega-Upload.
Paar Jahre später gab es dann...
... gerade dabei sind.
Moment, das ist die, ja, hier, besser.
Hahaha.
Mega-Upload.
Ja, Kermit, da hast du, da sagst du was, was Gutes.
Hallo?
What the fuck?
Hat er meine Tastatur nicht gekrappt?
Okay, da sagt er nämlich was Gutes und zwar, wow, what the fuck?
Was ist hier los?
Was ist denn Rappage her, Song?
Kann ich das hier aufmachen?
Boah, das ist ja grausam.
Dann lieber der Mega-Upload-Song.
Den Rappage her Song kenn ich nicht, nee.
Zumindest, wo ich jetzt eigentlich was sagen wollte, hier, genau.
Er schreibt, es ist nichts passiert vor dem Jahr davor, dass man noch alles gemacht hat.
Ja, die haben wirklich alles, alles scheu gemacht, was, was geht.
Und was man daran sieht ist, was, was, was man da wirklich schön dran sieht.
Gut, wie viel passiert wäre, ist an sich eh ungewiss, ja.
Aber man hat wirklich alles Mögliche gemacht und man konnte da wohl auch fett Geld verdienen zu dieser Zeit.
Man hat alles Mögliche gemacht, dass im Jahr 2000 nichts Großartiges passiert.
Woran man wieder sieht ist, wenn die Kacke so richtig am Dampfen ist und man damit rechnen muss,
dass es morgen auf den Sack gibt oder richtig auf die Fresse,
dann schafft es die Menschheit irgendwie oder die Menschen an sich,
schaffen es irgendwie dann in Anbetracht zu der drohenden Gefahr,
die ja schon quasi sehr bald eintritt, schaffen die was zu machen.
Wenn es so Dinger sind wie, ja, in 20, 30 Jahren passiert dann was Schlimmes, juckt keine Sau.
Das, das ist, das sehe ich auch so ein bisschen das Problem, wenn ich das,
ich kann ja ein bisschen schwätzen während ihr die Sache installiert,
wenn ich dann sehe, dass irgendwelche politischen Entscheidungen,
die jetzt eigentlich getroffen werden müssten,
dann gesagt wird, ach ja, wir machen einen Plan, der 2038 dann umgesetzt, was ist ein Schwachsinn?
Das juckt 2038 absolut nicht mehr, nicht nur keine Sau, das juckt noch nicht,
also man kann gar nicht beschreiben, wie wenig das 2038 überhaupt noch jemand juckt.
Übrigens, es ist auch eine Sache, ich kann jetzt ja,
eine Sache, die ich vermisse und warum ich auch wirklich absolut keinen Plan habe,
wen ich wählen soll, ich habe das Gefühl, niemand hat,
zumindest von den größeren Parteien, hat irgendwie eine Zukunftsvision,
die er sich traut auch mal der Welt mitzuteilen.
Es ist ja vollkommen okay, wenn jetzt einer sagt, ja, meine Zukunftsvision ist,
keine Flüge mehr, keine Kreuzfahrten mehr, das nicht, das nicht, das,
meinetwegen, das muss ich sagen, da kann ich immer noch sagen,
okay, die Zukunftsvision gefällt mir nicht, das wähle ich nicht,
aber wenigstens, wenigstens hat man dann eine.
So, aber aktuell äußert sich da keiner zu und ich meine nicht so Sachen,
nicht so Kleinscheiß, den sie immer erzählen, so nach dem Motto,
ja, unsere Stätten müssen elektroautofreundlicher werden, sonst was, alles schön und gut.
Nein, ich meine wirklich mal jemand, der sieht, die mal wirklich sagen,
okay, so stellen wir uns die Welt, meinetwegen 2030, 2040 vor
und das und das sind die Ziele, das und das müssen wir jetzt machen
und dann machen und dann machen, dass wir da hinkommen.
Da kann ich mir immer noch denjenigen raussuchen,
womit das am besten gefällt oder was ich für am realistischsten halte,
aber was aktuell gemacht wird, ist einfach nur mal so pauschal,
lustigerweise, die Piraten habe ich früher sogar ein paar Mal gewählt,
als es die noch gab, so irgendwie.
Ich weiß, dass es die noch theoretisch gibt, aber ja, also eigentlich ist da, da ist nix mehr da.
Der hat sich auspiratet.
So, da werden dann so Dinge, also es gibt so zwei Aussagen,
die in letzter Zeit, die so komplett einfach mal in den Raum geschmissen wurden,
um wohl gut Wetter bei speziellen Zielgruppen zu machen.
Das erste war, dass irgendein Politiker von sich gegeben hat, so nach dem Motto,
Ärzte dürfen nur noch in Krankenhäusern arbeiten, wenn sie Abtreibung vornehmen wollen.
Willst du das jetzt von oben erlassen oder was?
So, komplett ohne Kontext, einfach mal rausgehauen.
So, und dann habe ich vor ein paar Tagen gehört, hat irgendjemand gesagt,
ich glaube, es war sogar auf Hessen bezogen, hat irgendjemand gesagt,
ab jetzt sollen keine Straßen mehr gebaut werden.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das ist ohne Kontext drumherum, ist es komplett einfach nur irgendwas gesagt,
um was zu sagen, so komplett schwachsinnig einfach nur.
Hätte man sich jetzt dahingestellt und gesagt,
wir möchten, dass öffentliche Verkehrsmittel so gut ausgebaut werden,
dass man kein Auto mehr braucht.
Das wäre eine Aussage, da würde ich sagen, okay, in Ordnung, leuchtet mir ein.
Kann man immer noch sagen, ja gefällt mir nicht, finde ich gut, was auch immer.
Ich persönlich fände es gut.
Das ist eine Aussage, da kann ich was mit anfangen.
Aber einfach nur so pauschale Dinge, das ist genauso wie Breitbandziele.
Wir haben noch nicht ein einziges Breitbandziel erreicht.
Und anstatt dass man darauf eingeht, wie das mit Breitbandziele nicht geklappt hat,
macht man einfach neue Breitbandziele.
Das ist auch so eine geile Taktik.
Ach Moment, wie 50 MBit für jeden bis 2018 haben wir nicht geschafft.
Ah ja gut, dann machen wir Gigabit bis 2025.
Oder was auch immer das ist.
Und ich fände es wirklich gut, da gebe ich Captain Peng recht,
ich fände es wirklich gut, wenn man nicht nur einfach so pauschale Aussagen treffen würde,
sondern vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen erklären würde, in welchem Kontext man das meint.
Und ganz wichtig, das ist das, was ich mit Zukunftsvision meine,
die irgendwie da mir keiner vermitteln kann, wie kommt man dahin?
Weil es ist ja unrealistisch, wenn man sagt zum Beispiel,
wir können super umweltfreundlich sein werden,
allerdings ohne jegliche Einschränkungen alles so machen wie bisher.
Es gibt keinen Sinn!
Also zumindest nicht so pauschal.
Man könnte vielleicht sagen, okay, wir müssen das alles umweltfreundlicher machen
und in dem und den Bereichen wollen wir in Forschung investieren
und sonstige Geschichten so, dass man quasi in Zukunft kaum Einschränkungen spürt, was auch immer.
So ein bisschen mit Kontext drumherum, aber gibt es nicht.
Wenn du kannst und nicht ernsthaft den Leuten erzählen wollen,
wir können das super umweltfreundlich alles machen,
aber im Prinzip, wir machen einfach alles wie bisher, aber umweltfreundlich.
Das ergibt doch absolut keinen Sinn.
Oh Mist, ich müsste PXE überspringen.
Und dann frage ich mich so, ist das so?
Also was war zuerst da?
Gibt es diese sinnlosen Aussagen, weil man denkt,
ordentliche Aussagen würden die Leute nicht verstehen?
Oder sind sie zu blöd, ordentliche Aussagen zu machen?
Oder was war zuerst da?
Ich glaube, es ist beides.
Die meisten Leute haben gar keinen Bock,
sich komplexere Sachverhalte in ihrem Hirn zusammenzureimen.
Und dementsprechend kriegt man auch nur noch dummes Zeug vorgesetzt.
Okay, von Boot From Local.
Ja, das ist, deswegen habe ich halt auch den Eindruck,
was heißt Eindruck?
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es tatsächlich so ist,
dass man sich nicht darauf verlassen kann,
dass jemand was in seinem Interesse macht.
Hallo, bootet das jetzt oder bootet das jetzt nicht?
Ubuntu, hast du gebootet?
Oder nicht?
Ctrl, Alt, F2.
Ah, Ubuntu ist da.
Hä?
Was ist das für ein Kram?
Was habe ich für einen Benutzernahme genommen?
Max?
Max, hallo, ich darf nicht tippen.
Ubuntu, ich möchte tippen.
Hallo, tippen.
Was?
Rollen ist an.
Nein, Scroll Lock, nicht rollen.
Scroll.
Scroll Lock?
Okay.
Ah, MS habe ich genommen.
Ah, excellent.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
Okay, wir haben eine IP 2.1.4.3.
Jetzt gucken wir mal,
ob das Durchreichen von der Netzwerkkarte funktioniert.
1, 4, 3 als Root.
Ach, Moment, als Root geht ja nicht.
Als, als, ähm.
Frage, welches gute Microsoft Office benutzt ihr bei euch in der Firma?
Ähm, wir haben lokal, was ist das?
2019 installiert und Office 365.
Aber wie gesagt, ich verwende kein Office.
Ich verwende für nix Office.
Office sucked.
Machen wir noch schnell ein Update.
So.
Hä?
Oh.
Excellent.
So.
Na ja, gut.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal,
ob das Durchreichen der Netzwerkkarte ordentlich funktioniert.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich lasse mich ja öfters mal so während,
was läuft so zu aktuellen Themen aus.
Und ich möchte jetzt jetzt noch mal schnell abschließen.
Ähm, aus den genannten Gründen,
dass ich keinen da irgendwie aktuell für, ähm, fähig halte,
überhaupt irgendwie so was wie eine Zukunftsvision zu haben,
geschweige dann irgendwie in den sinnvollen Planen,
wie man da hinkommt, unabhängig davon, ob ich das ähnlich sehe.
Ja, wie die oder nicht.
Aber wenigstens erstmal so eine Zukunftsvision haben.
Und deswegen bin ich mir mittlerweile ziemlich sicher,
dass man sich absolut nicht darauf verlassen kann,
dass irgendjemand, also jetzt politische Entscheidung mäßig,
irgendjemand was macht für mich, dich, sonst wer.
Also, dass man nicht damit rechnen kann,
dass man so im eigenen Interesse vertreten wird.
Also, das hab ich mir abgeschminkt.
Und leider ist es halt so, dass die einzige Konsequenz daraus ist,
so doof es sich jetzt anhört, zu gucken,
dass man selbst so unabhängig ist, wie es irgendwie geht.
Also sprich, dass man selbst guckt, dass man seine Sachen,
wie man so schön sagt, im Trockenen hat,
dass man möglichst wenig auf seine Umwelt angewiesen ist.
Leider ist das so, dass es führt natürlich auch dazu,
dass deswegen die Leute immer weniger Rücksicht aufeinander nehmen
und sich immer beschissener verhalten und, äh,
ja, sich gegenseitig mehr abfangen.
Und, äh, so weniger, wie nennt man das so schön?
Nixlieb ist jetzt ein doofes Wort,
äh, weniger sich für ihre Umwelt interessieren.
Aber die meisten Leute können sich das heute schlicht und greiflich mal leisten.
Und nachdem man nicht damit rechnen muss,
dass irgendeiner dort im Interesse was macht,
wird es wahrscheinlich einfach nur noch immer schlimmer werden.
Ich mein, ich guck jeden Monat drauf,
wie viel Steuern ich bezahle, so.
Und dann überleg ich mir so davon,
was, was, was bekomm ich denn so mit,
was gemacht wird, so wirklich, wo ich sag,
okay, das wird irgendwie in meinem Interesse verwendet.
Also es ist weder Infrastrukturaufbau,
noch sind es irgendwie Krankensysteme,
noch sind es irgendwie Kindergartenplätze.
Ich hab zum Beispiel von meinem Nachbarn mitgekriegt,
dass die Tochter jetzt nicht in den Kindergarten kann,
obwohl die anderen zwei Kinder da auch schon hingehen.
Gerade Infrastruktur, wenn wir mal auf Internet und sonst was gucken,
wird deutlich schlechter.
Also was heißt deutlich schlechter?
Es wird besser, aber es wird im Vergleich zum Standard drum herum,
der Abstand wird immer größer.
Also da gibt es nicht so viele Sachen, wo ich sagen würde,
oh ja, dafür darf...
Ich mein, ich hab kein Problem, Steuern zu bezahlen,
aber es hätte doch irgendwie seinen Charme,
wenn man sagen könnte, okay, das wurde jetzt für was verwendet,
wo ich auch sag, ja, das ist wichtig.
Also den Eindruck hab ich jetzt einfach nicht.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es für nichts ausgegeben wird,
was mir was bringt.
Aber so von dem, wo ich sage, hey, ja, das ist was,
das wurde quasi von meinen Steuern geliebt,
und das finde ich gut, kommt wirklich ziemlich wenig.
Man sieht es ja auch schon, wenn man sich Nahverkehrzeug anguckt,
ja, man kann sagen, ja, okay, die Bahn ist privat,
Bahn und Telekom und sowas, das ist alles privat,
ist es ja auch nicht so wirklich 100%ig.
Aber ich bin auch der Ansicht, gerade was Krankenhäuser angeht,
das ist nichts, was großartig Gewinn machen soll.
Krankenhäuser sollte für die Versorgung der Einwohner
oder der Bevölkerung letztendlich sein
und nicht dort irgendwie großartig Geld machen.
Wenn man schon sieht, dass beispielsweise Leute
Hüft, Knie und sonst was OPs bekommen,
weil es Geld bringt, sobald es medizinisch irgendwie vertretbar ist.
Also sprich, man hätte jetzt die Auswahl,
okay, man könnte noch ein paar alternative Sachen probieren,
aber das zieht sich 2, 3 Jahre hin, kostet Geld.
Oder man macht jetzt einfach mal dicke Hüft-OP
und verdient da ein paar tausend, was weiß ich,
wie viel man da dran verdient, dann macht man lieber Hüft-OP.
Ob das jetzt so die beste Behandlung ist im Sinne,
dass jenigen, dem sein Knie kaputt ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Und woran man das auch gesehen hat,
dass eigentlich nur gelabert wird und nichts gemacht wird.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran, Anfang des Jahres,
wo so Corona richtig losging, wo sie gesagt haben,
oh, scheiße, wir haben zu wenig Krankenpfleger,
zu wenig Altenpfleger, zu wenig Gesundheitssystem und sonst was,
und die dann alle gesagt haben, oder auch Supermarktmitarbeiter.
Was haben die alle rumgeschleimt, ey?
So nach dem Motto, ihr seid unsere Helden im Alltag,
und dann sind sie dann ans Fenster gegangen
und haben die Leute klatschen lassen für die Gesundheitspflege.
Alles schön und gut, ich sag nicht, dass das schlecht ist,
aber davon können die sich alle nichts kaufen.
Und sie haben natürlich wild bekundet, so nach dem Motto,
oh, jetzt gibt's dicken Bonus, es gibt dicke Eckerhöhung und Geld,
und nix, nix.
Und was ist die logische Konsequenz für jemand daraus,
der so was erfährt, der kommt zu dem gleichen Schluss,
was ich eben auch schon gesagt hab, okay,
du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass jemand was in meinem Interesse macht.
Das heißt, das nächste Mal sind die Leute deutlich weniger,
wie nennt man das, wenn man weniger rücksichtsvoll ist,
also weniger rücksichtsvoll, und sagen dann, okay,
tja, da komm ich jetzt einfach mal nicht auf die Arbeit,
oder was weiß ich, da melde ich mich krank,
oder vielleicht sollten wir doch mal streiken,
dann sind da zu wenig Altenpfleger, oder sonst was,
da sterben halt ein paar Leute.
Das wird den Leuten nach und nach immer mehr egal,
weil sie halt merken, okay, es setzt sich keiner für mich ein.
Ja, aber es ist die logische, eigentlich die logische Entwicklung,
und das muss man eigentlich mal durchbrechen,
aber es geht eigentlich, es geht eher in die komplett andere Richtung.
Und dazu kommt, dass so was natürlich auch dazu führt,
dass extreme, also Leute extremer werden in ihren Ansichten,
wenn du permanent dir verarscht vorkommst,
natürlich wirst du irgendwann extremer in deinen Ansichten,
und das ist letztendlich der aktuellen Mainstreampolitik zu verdanken,
wie das gerade läuft oder nicht läuft.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es auch nicht gut,
für mich habe ich das schon seit ein paar Jahren festgestellt,
das einzige, was man machen kann, ist gucken,
dass man selbst genug für sich am Start hat,
dass man genug Geld hat, dass man ein Haus hat,
das muss ja kein Haus sein in dem Sinn,
ja, aber dass man einfach seine Sachen im Trockenen hat,
und nicht darauf angewiesen ist,
dass irgendjemand anderes was für dich macht,
weil da hast du ja echt gelitten mittlerweile.
Es ist ja auch schon der Witz, wenn man sich das anguckt,
wie das bei der Bahn läuft.
Die Bahn ist auch so ein Ding.
Das sollte eigentlich dafür da sein,
um die Leute mit, nennen wir es mal, Mobilität zu versorgen,
also sprich, dass man auch ohne Auto oder,
selbst wenn man ein Auto hat, dass man eben von A nach B
mit dem Zug fahren kann, zuverlässig,
und dass da nicht auch noch Fahrgäste gegeneinander ausgespielt werden.
Ich meine, wenn man sich das anguckt,
dass ICEs teilweise jetzt,
gab es beim letzten Chaos-Computer-Kongress,
gab es dann schon einen Vortrag dazu,
dass jetzt ICEs teilweise anhalten
und nicht mehr weiterfahren und wieder umdrehen,
also die lassen, keine Ahnung, die letzten zwei, drei Halte ausfallen
und drehen wieder um,
weil das dann in der Pünktlichkeitsstatistik besser aussieht.
Das ist der komplette Witz.
Was sollen denn die Leute sagen, die da drin, die da drin?
Meint ihr, so Leute fahren weiter mit der Bahn?
So Leute fahren auch nicht im Leben, die sagen,
okay, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl zwischen so einem Scheiß oder meinem Auto.
Mit dem Auto ist es vielleicht umweltschädlicher
und es ist vielleicht unangenehmer, auf so lange Strecken zu fahren,
aber ich komme wenigstens an.
Also meine persönliche Meinung ist,
Nahverkehr, gerade Nahverkehr, aber Fernverkehr ist natürlich auch,
aber gerade Nahverkehr müsste eigentlich,
dass man ernsthaft darüber nachdenken kann,
beispielsweise Verbrennerautos in Städten zu verbieten.
So Sachen spucken ja gerade rum.
Das ist eine Sache, die finde ich jetzt als wenig Autofahrer
an sich gar nicht so schlecht.
Wenn man sagt, okay, dann ist bessere Luft in der Stadt und sonst was,
aber das hängt ja an zwei ganz wichtigen Faktoren.
Erstens muss man sich fragen, okay, klar,
dass die Luft in der Stadt wird besser,
aber so wirklich umweltfreundlich ist das nicht,
solange das Zeug, mit dem du deine Batterien lädst
oder besser gesagt akkus lädst, eben nicht umweltschonend hergestellt wird.
Das muss die komplette Sache mit Akku herstellen, Autos herstellen
und sagen wir über einen Zeitraum, wie so ein Auto lebt, laden,
dass das günstiger ist oder umweltfreundlicher ist
als eben ein Verbrennerauto.
Erst dann hat das ja Sinn.
Wozu soll ich sonst Verbrennerautos verbieten,
wenn das auch nicht umweltschonend ist?
Das ergibt doch eigentlich auch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ein Elektroauto ist ja nicht per se umweltfreundlich,
nur weil es ein Elektroauto ist.
Der Strom muss ja irgendwo herkommen,
der Akku muss irgendwo gebaut werden,
das Auto muss auch irgendwo hergestellt werden.
Das heißt, du musst da auch die Voraussetzung für schaffen,
dass das funktioniert.
Das ist der erste Punkt, wo ich sage, okay,
aus aktuellem Gesichtspunkt vielleicht wenig sinnvoll,
Leute mit Verbrennerautos das Leben schwerer zu machen
in der Stadt, um auf die Arbeit zu kommen.
Und der zweite Punkt, der meiner Meinung nach
komplett außer Acht gelassen wird,
man muss das nicht durch verbieten machen,
sondern man muss den Leuten zeigen,
dass es Alternativen gibt.
Hätte man die Möglichkeit,
Frankfurt und Umgebung, sagen wir mal,
im 10-15-Minuten-Takt sicher zu fahren
und an seinen Arbeitsplatz zu kommen,
da würden viele Leute freiwillig, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher,
viele Leute freiwillig das Auto stehen lassen,
weil die wenigsten fahren gerne mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt morgens.
Mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt morgens ist kacke, sackt einfach nur.
So, und wenn es halt ordentliche Alternativen gäbe,
auf die man sich verlassen kann,
dann würden ganz viele Leute sagen,
ja gut, dann lassen wir das Auto daheim.
Aber solange das nicht der Fall ist,
was sollen die Leute denn machen?
Sollen die auf einmal nicht mehr arbeiten gehen oder was?
Naja, es gibt da so viele Dinge, wo ich mich frage,
irgendwie hat keiner so wirklich eine Zukunftsvision,
wo ich sage, okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Aber aktuell ist es halt so, ich meine,
ich fahre mit dem Zug, ich muss übrigens mal gucken,
ob der die Netzwerke hat durchgreifen,
ich fahre ja mit dem Zug und ich habe wirklich eine einfache Strecke.
Ich kann direkt quasi von mir losfahren nach Frankfurt an Hauptbahnhof.
Und sogar ich bin täglich fast täglich am Kotzen über irgendwas.
Und meine Strecke ist wirklich easy as fuck.
Wie ist das dann erst, wenn du eins oder zwei, drei Mal umsteigen musst?
Kannst du komplett knicken.
Wie reicht mir denn jetzt die Hardware durch?
War mal das für die Fernverkehr AG, okay.
Ja, aber das ist halt kacke, weil es letztendlich dazu führt,
dass die Leute kein Vertrauen in dieses Fortbewegungsmittel haben können.
Wenn du Zug fährst und nicht weißt, ob du ankommst,
schaffst nicht unbedingt Vertrauen in die Bahn.
So, wie leitet man denn jetzt hier Netzwerkgeräte durch?
Oder wie leitet man denn jetzt hier überhaupt Sachen durch?
PC-Device.
Was muss ich machen?
Hat er jetzt irgendwelche Schmerzen?
Z-Documentation.
Okay, welche Dokumentation?
Intel.
Jaja, VTD haben wir schon eingeschaltet.
Okay, also was muss man machen?
Crap.
Was?
Etc, Crap.
Wohin?
Etc, Defaults.
Etc, Defaults, Crap.
Und dann hier?
Geht quiet, machen wir schon mal raus.
Das?
Okay.
Das war's?
Update Crap.
Wie machst du das eigentlich,
dass du in deiner Baschest du gesuchen hast?
Steuerung R.
Oh, da sind wir noch nicht fertig.
Oh Leute, es ist 22 Uhr.
Ich muss gleich ins Bett.
Monkeys.
Jetzt aber hier.
Jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's aber eng.
Aber das mit dem Netzwerkgerät
durchreichen will ich noch ausprobieren.
Hallo, haben wir's heute noch mal?
Ja, natürlich.
Da hast du recht, MrKDH.
Klar, das Verkehrsaufkommen ist massig gestiegen
und in den letzten Jahren
hat man nicht richtig ausgebaut.
Man hat sogar eher abgebaut.
Man hat total viel abgebaut,
weil es zu viel gekostet hat.
Viele Strecken sind stillgelegt worden,
viele Kleise und viele Weichen und Gedöns wurden stillgelegt,
weil das zu viel gekostet hat.
So, und quasi das Verkehrsaufkommen ist gestiegen
und man hat die Sache noch abgebaut.
Man muss sich nicht wundern,
dass es dadurch schlechter wird.
Das sind halt gerade die Dinge,
wo ich mir denke, wenn du willst,
dass die Leute wirklich nicht mit dem Arbeit
auf das Auto fahren, was wenig Sinn ergibt,
dann muss das halt funktionieren.
Du musst halt zuverlässig ankommen,
was ja aktuell nicht so ist.
Und deswegen wirst du das auch nicht
den Leuten abgewöhnen können.
Und das, was man jetzt macht,
ist genau die falschen Treffen.
Wenn man damit jetzt anfängt und sagt,
hier, musst du damit noch mehr Steuern
fürs Auto bezahlen,
weil du auch kein Elektroauto hast,
jetzt musst du hier jenes machen.
Du kannst doch, guck mal,
also was ich halt nicht verstehe ist,
was ergibt es für einen Sinn,
wenn man die Leute,
die eh schon quasi am Limit sind,
noch weiter belastet und angeblich
mit Vorwänden,
wo die Voraussetzungen auch gar nicht
geschaffen sind.
Du kannst nicht zu dem 0815-Mensch,
der auf die Arbeit fährt und der sonst
dreimal mit der Bahn umsteigen müsste
oder auf einer scheiß Strecke ist,
zu sagen, nein, du darfst jetzt nicht
mehr mit dem Auto fahren
oder das für den so teuer machen,
dass er quasi mehr fürs Auto bezahlt,
um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sein.
Das ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Du kannst doch, das ist der zweite
oder das ist der dritte Schritt
vor dem ersten Schritt.
Ich sehe es auch so,
also ich fände es super,
wenn in Frankfurt weniger Autos wären.
Klar, und wenn wir noch Elektroautos hätten,
dass die Luft bleibt,
auch, da bin ich sofort dafür.
Aber ohne die Voraussetzungen dafür
kann das doch gar nicht funktionieren.
Und so dieser Zusammenhang
erschließt sich mir nicht,
warum man immer so Dinge entscheidet
und sie dann hinstellt so nach dem,
das muss jetzt gemacht werden,
ohne dass die Voraussetzungen dafür da sind.
Das ist wie unsere Breitbahnziele,
die wir noch nie erreicht haben,
aber angeblich schaffen wir jetzt
ein Gigabit bis, frag mich nicht, 2025.
Wie soll das denn gehen?
Das wächst doch nicht auf Bäumen.
Start.
Guck mal, da hat die Hardfels durchgereicht.
Exzellent.
Nee, doch.
Da hat die Hardfels durchgereicht.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert hat.
Ja, ich weiß, ich muss PXE noch abbrechen.
Ich muss die Bootreihenfolge ändern.
So.
Und jetzt.
Waiting for link up.
Ach, vielleicht, Leute, vielleicht ist net 0.
Net 0 ist schon die,
das wird schon die zweite Grafik,
das wird schon die Netzwerkkarte sein, oder?
Ja, das ist schon die zweite Netzwerkkarte.
Guck mal, wir sehen schon am PXE-Boot,
dass er das erkannt hat.
So, jetzt müsste er starten.
Der hat die Netzwerkkarte erkannt, ziemlich sicher.
Sonst würde er jetzt nicht,
sonst hätte er jetzt nicht
PXE-Boot von zwei Netzwerkkarten gemacht.
Ey, das hat funktioniert.
Leute, du dürftest jetzt einmal starten, Ubuntu, ne?
Booten, please.
Wir machen jetzt mal aus
und ändern mal die Bootreihenfolge
auf Disk
und den Rest mal mal aus.
Weil wir brauchen nur noch Disk.
Wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Warum bootet er jetzt nicht?
Okay, machen wir mal aus.
Stop.
So, und jetzt sollte er eigentlich Disk booten.
Moin, Kyokun.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Bootet.
Ja, booting vom Hard Disk.
Postchamp.
Kann es sein, dass er Probleme hat
mit durchgereichten PCI-Geräten?
Weil er bootet nicht.
Kyokun sagt, habe letztens,
äh, habe letzten Donnerstag mit Praktikum angefangen,
habe Skype for Business 2000.
Oh, Painschamp.
Noch nicht mal Teams.
Das ist, das ist schlecht.
Painschamp.
Skype for Business 2000.
Der größte Scheiß überhaupt.
Okay, der bootet nicht mehr,
wenn ich die, wenn ich die, ähm,
wenn ich das durchgereicht habe.
Wir gucken mal, ob es da dran liegt.
Habe ich schon.
Äh, ich habe schon, habe schon das Zeug aktiviert im Crap.
Booting vom Hard Disk.
Komm mal, das liegt da dran.
Jetzt bootet er.
Jaja, im Pios ist alles an.
Nee, der bootet nicht mit durchgerei...
Oh, ist das jetzt gelb?
Der bootet nicht mit durchgereichter Netzwerkarte.
Das, ich bin mir aber ziemlich sicher,
das liegt nicht an Proxmox.
Das liegt an diesem Kackboard,
dass das nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ziemlich sicher, dass das nicht mag.
Leute, es ist spät.
Ich muss jetzt gleich off.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Also, ich muss sagen,
jetzt mal so abschließen,
das neue Proxmox gefällt mir viel besser
als die letzte Version.
Und der hauptsächliche Punkt ist,
man kann jetzt einen Container laufen lassen,
in dem man direkt Docker laufen lassen kann.
Und man braucht keine unsinnige VM mehr,
wenn man gar keine VMs verwenden will.
Das finde ich sinnvoll.
Das UI ist gewöhnungsbedürftig,
aber ich denke, man gewöhnt sich dran.
Das war jetzt bescheuerter Satz,
wenn es gewöhnungsbedürftig ist.
Aber ich denke, man gewöhnt sich dran.
So super...
Intuitiv finde ich es nicht,
aber man gewöhnt sich dran.
Ziemlich sicher.
Ob ich es einsetzen werde,
weiß ich nicht, eher nicht.
Wie gesagt,
ich bin mit meinem aktuellen Setup
aus Ubuntu Server
und ein paar Docker-Container
über Docker Compose
bin ich ehrlich gesagt recht zufrieden.
Mal gucken, ob er sich ausschaltet.
Ob er das hinbekommt.
Fährt er sich runter?
Ah.
Resident Sleeper Champ.
Was würde dir noch bei Proxmox gefehlt?
Also...
Nachdem ich mir gerade gestern
dieses Cynology-Geschichte angeguckt habe,
was ich da schick fand,
war das Management von Docker-Containern.
Das war ganz praktisch.
Auf der anderen Seite
ein Ubuntu mit einem Docker-Truf oder so
und dann ein eigenes Compose-Container.
Das war ganz praktisch.
Auf der anderen Seite
ein Ubuntu mit einem Docker-Truf oder so
und dann ein eigenes Compose-Container.
Das ist auch okay.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal Gedanken machen.
Direkte Docker-Integration
wäre auf jeden Fall nützlich.
Aber so wie es jetzt ist, ist okay.
Es sind Debian drunter.
Man kann mehr oder weniger alles machen.
File Server hätte man noch mal
das durchreicht.
Aber alles in allem
ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich glaube trotzdem werde ich nicht verwenden,
weil ich bin mit meinem aktuellen Setup
Ubuntu Server 5.6.7-Container drauf.
Fertig. Relativ zufrieden.
Und nachdem ich eh keine
VMs laufen habe,
ist das eigentlich
Overkill, so was wie Proxmox zu verwenden.
Hast du PCE-Pass-True jetzt hinbekommen?
Ja.
Aber die Form hat nicht mal gestartet.
Aber das schiebe ich mal auf das Board.
Dass das Board nicht für so was gedacht ist.
Oder aber ich müsste mal probieren,
wobei ich den anderen PCE-Express-Slot
nicht nehmen kann, da ist die Karte zu groß.
Dass der mehr durchgereicht hat, als nötig war.
Und deswegen rumgespackt hat.
Oder ich irgendwelche Optionen noch setzen müsste.
Ich muss mal ausprobieren.
Aber ansonsten ist es ganz praktisch.
Ich finde, die Oberfläche könnte noch
ein bisschen strukturierter sein.
Es ist jetzt für mich nicht intuitiv gewesen,
was zu finden.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so
das große Problem.
Wenn man das ein paar Tage verwendet,
kommt man da ziemlich gut rein, denke ich.
Ja, eine Sache, die ich noch richtig cool
finden würde, ist, wenn man
keine Isos downloaden müsste.
Sondern wenn das das für einen machen könnte.
So eine reine Convenience-Geschichte.
Also sprich, man wählt aus,
ok, ich möchte nur bunte 20.04 installieren.
Und er guckt nach, aha,
ich hab noch kein Iso dafür
oder noch kein Image dafür,
dann lade ich dir das schnell runter.
Das wäre auch kein allzu großer Akt,
dort irgendwie ein File zu hinterlegen.
Die müssten im Prinzip einfach nur
ein File mitliefern,
Server-Distributionsname,
Download-Url,
ein paar Alternativen im Hintergrund
ein Wegaht machen oder sowas.
Das stelle ich mir jetzt nicht so kompliziert,
vor sowas einzubauen.
Kann man mal Proxmox,
Logs und so auslagern?
Das weiß ich nicht,
das habe ich nicht ausprobiert jetzt.
Aber nachdem die da
ziemlich viel Cluster-Gedöns
stehen hatten,
würde ich mal drauf tippen,
dass man,
aber ob es mit Logs geht, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich würde mal drauf tippen,
dass man da schon was machen kann.
Aktuell habe ich halt von der SSD laufen,
aber klar, wenn man es vom USB-Stick laufen will,
das ist ja gerade auch das Schöne,
was ESX macht und
was habe ich letztens,
ja auch hier,
gestern, dieses Anology-Ding,
da ist ziemlich viel,
ziemlich viel Read-Only
auf dem USB-Stick.
Weil USB-Sticks
gehen halt wirklich gerne mal kaputt.
Das habe ich unten
an dem Raspberry Pi,
wo mein Unify-Controller
läuft und wo mein
Web-Interface für die ganzen Kameras
läuft, habe ich das auch so.
Das nimmt ab und zu mal von den Kameras
ein bisschen was auf und das schreibe ich
auch alles auf dem USB-Stick, weil ich Schiss habe,
dass die SD-Karte kaputt geht.
Wie ist es lieber, der USB-Stick
geht kaputt, da sind ein paar
Videoaufnahmen weg,
als dass das ganze Ding abkackt.
Die Musik, die Playlist
gefällt mir, die ist schön entspannt.
Ist das hier so?
Aha, exzellent.
Das muss ich speichern.
Wir machen mal einen Ordner.
Wir machen hier mal einen Ordner.
Ordner, New,
Folder, Musik.
Wo ist der Ordner hin?
Das ist übrigens auch eine Sache, die ich an Chrome nicht mag.
Dass man das nicht so ohne Weiteres
gescheit verschieben kann.
So, zack.
Musik.
M.
Zack.
Der Desktop, der ist exquisite.
Bester Desktop.
Oder
Chat meint ihr wirklich, irgendjemand
hat noch einen aufgeräumteren Desktop als ich.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja.
ESX funktioniert weiter.
ESX komplett im RAM.
Also das ist komplett
mehr oder weniger
auf Read-Only geschaltet an alles.
Okay.
Okay Chat, ich werde jetzt ins Bett.
Brauchen wir noch Autromusik?
Wie sieht es heute aus? Muss Autromusik sein?
Autromusik.
Ja.
Also wir sehen uns die Tage,
vielleicht sogar morgen schon.
Machts gut, bis denn.
See you.
Musik.